احنا اليوم نقول المفروض ما نعترف
بالتدريب اقل من ست اشهور المفروض اي احد
قبل لا يتخرج من الجامعه يتدرب لمده ست
شهور بس خوف بدان انه كل شي انت قاعد
ترميه على الناس انت دور شغفك انت راح
ابحث عن الفرص انت اعرف ش الجديد بس انا
ما اعرف انا ما احتاج احد يساعدني مين
اللي بيمسك يدي ويخليني اعرف ش شغفي ثم
خليني اعرف ش المستجدات اللي صارت في
السوق ش المهارات اللي احتاجها يعني اتذكر
واحد من زملائي في الشركه كان يقول يا اخي
ترى لو الحكومه اشتغلت ما صار عندنا
بزنس ما في
صحيح لانه كان العمل الحكومي في رتابه وفي
هدوء اليوم العمل الحكومي يعني
[موسيقى]
مخيف
هذا سقراط من شركه ثمانيه وانا عمر
الجريسي استضيف قاده التحول وقاده الاعمال
وقاده الراي ضيف حلقتنا اليوم هو المهندس
انس المديفر الرئيس التنفيذي لبرنامج
تنميه القدرات البشريه احد برامج تحقيق
رؤيه السعوديه 20 30 يمكن هذا مو باول
برنامج سبق استضفنا ثلاث او اربع برامج من
برامج تحقيق رؤيه فما توسعنا كثير في شرح
مفهوم البرامج وارتباطها بالرؤيه عشان ما
يعني ناخذ من وقتكم فاللي مهتم يفهم هذا
الجزء يرجع للحلقات السابقه مع قاده
البرامج وح نحطها في وصف الحلقه لكن احنا
دخلنا مباشره على مفهوم تنميه القدرات
البشريه ايش هي القدرات الاربعه اللي هم
بعد بحثهم وصلوا الى انها هي الاساسيه
لجعل المواطن السعودي منافس عالميا تكلمنا
على التحديات اللي واجهوها لما سووا المسح
او تحليل الوضع الراهن مثل انخفاض التحاق
السعوديين في مرحله ما قبل الابتدائي في
رياض الاطفال موضوع قصر ايام الدراسه
مقارنه بالمعدلات
العالميه مع موضوع درجاتنا المتدنيه في
اختبارات الكتابه والقراءه والحساب اللي
تقاس عالميا موضوع الفجوه بين مخرجات
التعليم وسوق العمل واللي تؤدي الى تاخر
التحاق بعض الخريجين بسوق العمل كل هذه
التحديات تحدث عنها ضيفنا وذكر ش اللي تم
فيها ش اللي تحقق فيها حتى الان ثم عرجنا
على موضوع القيم لان البرنامج هذا مسؤول
ايضا عن القيم ش اهميتها ش القيم اللي
احنا مركزين عليها كيف بنحاول نشتغل على
غرسها في المجتمع وختمنا بمجموعه من
اسئلتكم الثمينه مثل موضوع كيف هم مهتمين
باللغه العربيه ومؤتمر
القادم بلغه غير اللغه
العربيه الملف الرقمي الموحد لكل
الطلاب ايضا صرفنا عننا ليش لم يتم حتى
الان تكلمنا على ما الذي يقدم للفئه
العمريه ما بعد 60 سنه هل التعليم فقط
محصور على فتره الدراسه وسوق العمل او في
اشياء ما بعد هذه المرحله الى اخر اسئلتكم
الثمينه هذه الحلقه برعايه شركه صفا اما
الان اترككم مع الحوار حياك الله ابو دانه
شرفتنا ونورتنا حياك الله ابو عبد الرحمن
سعيد بوجودي معك اليوم اطني سالفه الستيكر
حق
شادن
ا
طبعا المفروض ما قلتلك قبر اللقا ما نفوت
حنا اي فرصه كل معلومه ناخذها ونحولها
لصالحنا شادن جرافيكس ديزاينر عندنا
بالبرنامج وما شاء الله يعني من المبدعين
توظفت في البرنامج
فريش قبل لا اجي حتى وما شاء الله متميزه
في ومبدعه بالعمل فانا دائما لما نطلب
اشياء هويات وكذا الارتست ياخذون وقتهم
يروقون انا عجل شوي مو بشوي
عجل فكل ما جيت ما خلصتو مره كانوا شغالين
على لوجو اعتقد حق برنامج خادم الحش
الابتعاث يعني توزد ان هاوس يعني في
البرنامج و مع الاطلاق الاستراتيجيه فدخلت
قت ما خلصتوا في احد صورني راحت سوت ستكر
وكتبت ما خلصتوا فصر ما سالت عن موضوع حطت
بالاستيكر يعني للزملاء يعني ما خلصتو
وهذه كانت اللي جاب طريق انه قاعد اقول لك
انه واحنا نتلقى اسئله الناس في واحد يبدو
لي عمل معك او ما زال يعمل يمكن ي تدور
يمكن عشان تفصله يقول انه حار ابو دانه
حار مره يعني هو يثني على تعاملك الشخصي
بس يقول انه حار كل شيء بخلصه امس ودائما
فوق روؤسنا ولا يوقف فمنها جا طاري ما
خلصته المفاجاه انه هذا الشخص الحار يقود
اخر البرامج اللي
اطلقت فما خلصتوا ما اطلق برنامجكم ليش
تاخر اي طبعا
بجاوب على الحار حار ترى بس
اليوم الطموح الرؤيه والحراك اللي قاعد
يصير في الرؤيه يخليك يعني ي هاف تو كاتش
اب
لازم لازم تكون اصلا يعني تفكر ما تفكر
بالخطوه الجايه تفكر خمس ست خطوات يمكن
هذا اللي دائما اعمل فيه مع الفريق لا
تفكر بالخطوه اللي جايه فكر خمس ست خطوات
ش اللي
بعدها فلما يكونوا مفكر خطوتين وانا افكر
بالرابعه الخامسه يقول يا اخي انت حارص
خلي نخلص الخطوه الاولى والثانيه لكن
اعتقد
يمكن هذه طاقه اكثر من حراره وانرجي وشغف
اللي قاعد يصير يعني في الرؤيه والزامل
والامثله اللي قاعدين نبنيها احنا ما قد
صار ابد يعني اليوم احنا اول نروح انا كل
شغلي ترى قبل استشارات واشتغلت كثير مع
الحكومه وشفت استراتيجيات قبل مع قطاعات
يعني يعني اذكر واحد من زملائي في الشركه
كان يقول يا اخي ترى لو الحكومه اشتغلت ما
صار عندنا
بزنس ما في
صحيح لانه كان العمل الحكومي ف رتابه وفي
هدوء اليوم العمل الحكومي يعني مخيف من
السرعه
والتركيز استغلال الفرص وهذا كله ترى جامع
الرؤيه قبل الرؤيه الدوام خلص ساعه اين
احنا الشركات الاستشاريه نقعد نط
ما فيه
الحماس والطاقه اللي تشوفها اليوم بالجهه
الحكوميه الجهه الحكوميه كلها يعني خلايا
نحل يعني انا بحكم البرنامج نعمل مع
وزارات متعدده فتلقى الوزير الصباحي اللي
يقوم الساعه س س ونص بالكثير يكون في
المكتب من بعد الفجر صاحي وتلقى الوزير لا
اللي جدوله يبدا من بعدم بعد الفجر فهو
يعني انا انا اتذكر في واحده من
الاجتماعات مع واحد من اصحاب المعالي وكان
في لجنه وتاخرت
اللجنه ثمان الصبح موجود افكر مره احنا
نسوي لجاننا البرنامج عاده
مع مع اجتماع مجلس الوزراء عشان تضمن كل
الاصحاب المعالي موجودين سويها قبل المجلس
اتذكر سوينا اجتماعنا الساعه 10 في
الديوان الساعه 12 صار مجلس الوزراء
الساعه اين بدا اجتماع مجلس اصاد والتنميه
كان عندنا عرض خلصنا تقريبا الساعه 4
الساعه خمس بدا اجتماع اللجنه
الاستراتيجيه امتد اجتماع اللجنه
الاستراتيجيه الى ما بعد نص منتصف الليل
يعني انا انا طلعت من ذاك الاجتماع وتعرف
اجتماعات اللجنه تطول طلعت اعتقد الساعه
اتين ونص سالت واحد من المرافقين مع اصحاب
المع متى طلعتوا قالت 6 الصباح الساعه عشر
الوزير جاي داوم يعني فهال الانرجي هذه ما
هي هذه يعني مومنتم على مستوى كل الاجهزه
الحكوميه وهنا يعني على الطاري احنا اليوم
سعداء باستضافته على طار رؤيه يعني
باضافتك كرئيس تنفيذي لبرنامج تنميه
القدرات البشريه واحد من برامج تحقيق
الرؤيه
اللي كثير اسئله عن مراحل تطوره وولادته
وليش تاخر وليش تغير وليش دمجت معه اشياك
يعني متعدده جدا يميز هذا البرنامج انه
يكاد يكون البرنامج الوحيد اللي متمحور
حول الانسان في الوقت اللي اغلب البرامج
الاخرى تتكلم على المرافق على الخدمات على
التمويل على ميزانيات بالتاكيد كلها فييه
تصب في الانسان بشكل غير مباشر حتى جوده
الحياه تقدم فعاليات عشان الانسان بس اقصد
انتم البرنامج الوحيد اللي مباشره
يستهدف مواطن منافس عالميا هذه كلمه انا
بالنسبه لي صيغه بذكاء لان تلخص كل شي
تبغون
تسوونه بس في كواليس كثيره للبدايات ودنا
انك تعطينا اياها وتعرفنا على ش علاقتكم
انتم ببقيه البرامج وبالرياض واضح طبعا
يمكن زي ما تفضلت برامج الرؤيه اغلبها
جايه يعني نوعا ما قطاعي فيرتك فعندك قطاع
تبغى الطوره القطاع الصحي الصناعه
والقطاعات الم الرحم الاسكان بالضبط احنا
يمكن احنا يمكن صندوق الاستثمارات نكد
نكون البرامج الوحيده اللي جايه افقيه
هورزنتل والتحول الوطني التحول الوطني ترى
داخل قطاعات بشكل بشكل كبير
في بعض الاشياء التشريعيه السياسات وكذا
والتحول الرقمي داخله لكن مستواها يعني
تعقيدها اقل من لما تتكلم على على القدرات
البشريه
فجاي يعني هزنت هو ترى صحيح بالضبط صحيح
البرنامج ما اعلن عنه الا في 20
21 لكن هذا ما يعني انه ما كان في عمل قبل
كان في ترى مبادرات من بدايه الرؤيه
انطلقت لكن توجه البرنامج
واستراتيجيته زي ما انت عارف بدا في تعزيز
الشخصيه الوطنيه كانت الاهداف المسنده
للبرنامج وبعدين صار في مراجعه و وصار في
توجيه انه او توجه انه يكون برنامجين وهذا
كان مقترح حتى من اعتقد لجنه برنامج تعزيز
الشخصيه الوطنيه
انه يمكن في في ذاك الوقت الحمل اكبر على
على
البرنامج وطلع يمكن في 2018 اعلن انه
استحداث برنامج تنميه القدرات البشريه
ووضع له الاهداف وكان في يعني عمل على على
الخطه عرض اكثر من من مره وزي ما انت عارف
يعني
احيانا الطموح يكون اعلى من الشيء اللي
يقدم
ا صار في اعاده
مراجعه للمقترحات والتوجهات الاستراتيجيه
الى ما ما اعتمدت لكن ترى بادين من زمان
وكان في عمل البرنامج بشكل نهائي واطلاقه
صار في 20 21 وانت عارف قبلها كان الجائحه
لا يمكن انك تطلق برنامج والناس يعني بس
من متى انتم جاهزين تقريبا من 2019 يعني
لا من 20 20 تقريبا منتصف 2020 كان خلاص
في وضوح وجاهز بس بسبب ظروف الجائحه لا
يمكن انك تطلق لكن كان في عمل والعمل ترى
من 2016 من بدايه الرؤيه كان في استثمار
في التعليم بدات اشياء في التحول الوطني
في استثمار كذلك في التدريب في الموارد
البشريه وفي تغييرات سياسات تشريعيه ولو
ما بدينا من ذاك الوقت ما حققنا اللي
حققناها اليوم و لو بنعرف هالبرنامج وش شو
برنامج بكل بساطه يركز على الانسان
السعودي ما في حد للعمر يعني احنا نقول
تركيزنا المواطن السعودي ش نبغاه نبغاه
جاهز المستقبل ش نبغاه بعد نبغاه يكون
منافس عالميا هذا هذا التركيز الاساسي من
يعني اتذكر واحد من اصحاب المعالي يقول من
المهدي الى اللحد احنا حتى المتقاعدين
قاعدين نفتح فرص نعزز
مشاركتهم الاقتصاديه نغير في السياسات
العامه اللي تمكن قدراتنا البشريه انها
تكون اكثر جاهزيه واكثر
تنافسيه
ويمكن لو نحاول نبسط المفهوم هذا ش
القدرات البشريه ترى ما احد ما في ما في
برنامج في العالم وهذا احنا يعني نثبتها
بدراسات ما في احد اخذ رحله تنميه القدرات
البشريه حتى احنا اليوم نقول حتى من قبل
الولاده من الاسره ومتى يفكرون يجيبون
ابناء والعمل اللي يقوم فيه مجلس شؤون
الاسره الى ما بعد التقاعد كيف اعزز من
المشاركه الاقتصاديه والمشاركه
الاجتماعيه المتقاعدين ش القدرات البشريه
هذا الفشن نفسه والتعريف كان في خلاف الاو
س تعرفه شي البنك الدولي عرف شي الامم
المتحده تعرف شي احنا عرفنا تعريف شفنا كل
الجهات كيف تعرف تنميه القدرات البشريه
واخترنا التعريف اللي احنا نشوفه مناسب
لنا وعرفناها باربع اشياء في مهارات
اساسيه سميها البيزك سكز هذ هذه اللي
المفروض كل احد تكون عنده قراءه كتابه
حساب ومهارات رقميه اليوم المهارات
الرقميه المفروض انها مهاره اساسيه انت ما
تقدر
تستخدم الحساب تفتح حساب في البنك وتخلص
معاملاتك الحكوميه اذا ما عندك المهارات
الرقميه الاساسيه هذا اول اول باكيت
الباكيت الثاني سميناها مهارات هذ
المهارات الاساسيه هذه المهارات الاساسيه
حلو الباكيت الثاني سميناه او المكون
الثاني مهارات المستقبل وهذه المفروض
متغيره اليوم احنا عرفناها ثلاث مهارات
رئيسيه المهارات التفكير
العليا بالانجليزي يسمونها هاي اوردرك
سكيلز هذه كيف تحلل كيف تحل مشاكلك كيف
يعني قدراتك التحليليه المنطق لازم كل احد
يكون عنده منطق ولوجك وعنده مهارات
تحليليه فهذا واحد وهذه يعني مهمه لانه
الاوتوميشن ما يغير ما يقدر يستبدل
والتقنيه ما تستبدل مهارات التحليل اللي
عند البشر شيء ثاني وهذا برضه شيء مهم
المهارات الاجتماعيه والعاطفيه وهذا كان
يمكن ما التفت
السنوات الماضيه كيف
نطور المهارات الشخصيه السوفت سكيلز
والمهارات العاطفيه عند الناس
التقنيه يعني ما تقدر يكون عندها عاطفه
فور ناو طبعا لكن متوقع مع الذكاء
الاصطناعي انه يمكن يكون في يعني
حتى التقنيه يكون عندها نوعا ما جزء من
السنسر اللي تحس
في في المشاعر الناس اللي امامها
فالمهارات الاجتماعيه والعاطفيه لانه
العمل سوق العمل معقد ويتطلب تواصل بين
يعني فرق مختلفه من يعني خلفيات مختلفه من
جنسيات مختلفه احيانا فهذا شيء نركز عليه
في في مهارات المستقبل اخر شيء المهارات
العمليه والبدنيه صحه الانسان اهتمامه
باداره الماليه والشخصيه اهتمامه بحتى
مظهره لحظ ايش دخل صحه الانسان في الشؤون
الماليه مهارات بدنيه
انك انت كيف تدير ماليتك كيف تدخر كيف
والبدنيه انه صحتك ولياقتك وعارف انت حط
وعاء واحد ذولي لان لانها كلها بيرسونال
يعني عارف شلون على شخصك انت يعني دير
نفسك بالضبط فهذه
الثلاثه اللي عرفناها كمهارات مستقبل نجي
لرقم ثلاثه من مكونات القدرات البشريه
القيم والقيم
يعني لازم نفهم ش نقصد بالقيم ش تعريفنا
القيم القيم ترى هي معتقدات عندي وعندك
عبد الرحمن وعند اي فرد تحرك سلوكك انا
عندي قيمه الكرم انا اتصرف بكرم مع الناس
انا عندي
قيمه الامانه لما اشوف شيء ماه لي انا
امين واروح اقول هذا الشيء ما هو لي هذا
الشخص اخر فهي اعتقادات
عندنا يعني تحرك وتاثر على على سلوكنا
وهذا طبعا يعني فيه دراسات كثيره عليه وين
مصادر هال الاعتقادات هذه وكيف وعرفنا
كذلك مجموعه من من القيم اليوم احنا احنا
نستهدف ونستهدف اننا نعزز
ونب الجانب الاخير
المعارف المعارف هذا كان هو اهم شيء في
القدرات البشريه في
السابق كان اللي عنده معلومه ومعرفه هو
الشخص المناسب اليوم المعلومه جاهزه
ويمكن اذا يعني احنا دورنا اليوم في
المعارف كيف نمكن الناس انه يوصل للمعلومه
ما نبغى الناس
تحفظ المعلومه كان تركيز التعليم في كل
الدول في السابق على المعلومه تحفظ وتعرف
المعادلات لكن اليوم احنا نركز على
المعارف المرتبطه في سوق العمل في في
برنامجنا المعارف التخصصيه اللي تساعدك
انك تنافس عالميا في في سوق عمل عالمي ماه
بس يعني احنا نشوف سوق العمل بشكل بشكل
الاشمل فهذه مكونات القدرات البشريه اللي
احنا نعمل عليها نتكلم عن مهارات اساسيه
مهارات م ققبل اتكلم
على القيم القيم والمعارف صحيح هذه هي
الاربع تعريفات للقدرات البشريه صحيح
وانتم على عكس المعتاد
تستهدف الانسان السعودي من قبل ولادته الى
وفاته هذه كلها تعتبرون انها نطاق انتم
تشتغلون عليه مو بس مهتمين بمرحله عمريه
مرحله المدرسه ولا مرحله العمل انتم
ماخذين الرحله كامله حق الانسان
صحيح ولو بنتكلم
على على طريقه تصميم مبادرات انتم يعني
تعقيد برنامجكم انه مثلا في صندوق الات
العامه الموضوع شوي ابسط بانه عندنا مشكله
هنا اسس له شركه عندنا مشكله هنا او عندنا
فرصه هنا خصص لها فند فالموضوع كتصميم
نوعا ما اسهل انتوا تتكلم على الانسان
وتتكلم عليه من قبل ولادته الى وفاته شلون
صممت مبادرات واضح طبعا اذكر واحد من
اصحاب المعالي يقول برامج الرؤيه
الهاردوير البرنامج هذا السوفت وير السوفت
وير ف طبعا قبل المبا برنامجكم اسمو سيدي
ولي العهد الله يحفظه رئيس اللجنه
[موسيقى]
الاعضاء فيه من الديمان سايد ومن جهه
الطلب فوزير الصناعه وزير
السياحه وزير
الاتصالات في من جهه التشريع وضع السياسات
وزير الموارد البشريه
وزير الاقتصاد وفي من جهه العرض وزير
التعليم
وكذلك معالي رئيس مجلس اداره هيئه تقويم
التعليم والتدريب معالي محافظ المؤسسه
العامه للتدريب التقني والمهني من العرض
برضه نسيت معالي وزير التجاره ومعالي وزير
الثقافه كذلك يمكن الثقافه برضه هورزنتل
في العرض وفي الطلب
وفي اسمه وزير الثقافه في العرض وفي الطلب
وكذلك
في اللي هو في العرض الطلب في السياسات
كذلك من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم
ورفاهيه الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول
سكنيه مبتكره ومستدام مع شركه صفاء
للاستثمار المزيد في وصف
[موسيقى]
الحلقه عشر دقائق صباحك كفيله اطلاعك على
ما يهمك وييك من احداث
العالم الفجر اخباري وننشر منه حلقه فجر
كل يوم نتكلم فيها عن جديد العالم من
احداث واخبار ونشرحها ضمن سياقها من تاريخ
تطورها كل يوم بيومه كل خبر بوقت بودكاست
الفجر متوفر على جميع منصات البودكاست
اشترك وتابع
[موسيقى]
الجديد ما شاء الله يعني تقسيمه الاعضاء
رهيبه بس نرجع لموضوع تصميم المبادرات
شلون صممت توها بحيث انها يعني تخدم هذا
النطاق الواسع وهذا الاحتكاك المعقد مع
الانسان انا بدي يمكن نتكلم على
الاستراتيجيه قبل اوكي لان المبادرات هي
مكونات في الاستراتيجيه احنا كيف عملنا
على استراتيجيه البرنامج
و ويعني وطلعنا بالخطه العمل اللي اليوم
نعمل عليها بدينا طبعا باهداف رؤيه
المملكه 20 30
كتوجد عامه وكان في حتى توجيهات من اللجنه
الاستراتيجيه على البرنامج هذا ش المفروض
يحقق
ش مكتوبه جتنا ممتاز ش
طموحنا للبرنامج هذا تعزيز التنافسيه
المواطنه العالميه تركيز على الفرد تركيز
على المنظومه كذلك يعني توجيهات واضحه
بدينا هذا كانت نقطه الانطلاق عندنا اهداف
احنا مسؤولين عنها لها مكونات لها
يعني مؤشرات المفروض تقيسها اول شيء
سويناه
سوينا يعني تحليل للوضع الراه بشكل كامل
درسنا كل شيء من الاعمال اللي قاعدين نقوم
فيها في الاسره ودورها في تمكين يعني
القدرات البشريه الى
منظومه التعليم العام من مراحل الطفوله
المبكره ورياض
الاطفال الى الى مرحله ما بعد الثانوي
التدريب التقني والتعليم الجامعي الى
الاستثمار في التدريب في في سوق العمل
والاستثمار في تدريب الباحثين عن عمل الى
فرص المتاحه
ل حتى المتقاعدين ومنهم خارج سوق العمل
وطلع عندنا ام اري واضح عرفنا وين الفجوات
ش اهم التحديات اللي
لاحظتوه كروس يعني وع
على يمكن في ثلاث تحديات
يمكن اهم اهم التحديات اللي لقينا انه في
فجوه كبيره يمكن اول تحدي موضوع رياض
الاطفال رياض
الاطفال الكل يعتقد ان هذا شيء
رفاهيه وكان
محدود الاستثمار فيه يعني المراه العامله
تحرص ان تدخل اطفالها في في رياض اطفال
وبعض الاسر اللي عندها يمكن اهتمام في
تنميه قدرهم الغالب المجتمع ما كان يست كم
كانت النسبه 16% 16% فقط يدخلون من
الاطفال في السعوديه يدخلون مرحله ما قبل
اول ابتدائي صحيح وهذا لما نقارنه مع
الدول اللي انظمتها اقتصاداتها متقدمه
يعني في فجوه كبيره نتكلم على متوسط الاو
اي سي دي 80% طبعا 16 هذا يوم بدينا في
2017 اي اليوم اليوم احنا ترى بالشرك
34% م استهدفنا في 2025 40% م استهدفنا في
20 30 90%
ويمكن في لقاءه معك معالي الدكتور فهد
اشار كيف كيف قدرنا
نحقق الاعداد هذه يعني وزاره التعليم عملت
عمل صراحه ذكي اننا نستغل البنيه التحتيه
اللي موجوده اليوم في وزاره التعليم ونفتح
يعني اليوم تستغرب اخوي عمر لما اقول لك
بعض المناطق الطرفيه وصل فيها الحاق
الاطفال في رياض الاطفال
40% خارج المدن الرئيسيه تحدي اليوم ترى
اكثر في المدن الرئيسيه عجيب بسبب التوجه
اللي صار صار في استثمار ذكي في البنيه
التحتيه الحاليه اللي في وزاره التعليم
اتيحت رياض الاطفال في المناطق الطرفيه في
مدارس الابتدائيه لانه عندك مساحات
استثمار بسيط انا ابني لمنطقه داخل
المدرسه اللي موجوده اوريدي اربع خمس فصول
لرياض الاطفال واعين لي معلمات ومشرفه انا
اقدر مباشره اتيح الخدمه هذه و وحطينا حتى
حاولنا انه برض ه الاستثمار هذا يكون مبني
على جوده حطينا معايير واضحه انه ش الخدمه
اللي نبغاها في في رياض الاطفال فهذا كان
اول يمكن واكبر تحدي وسمحلي اسال ليش
الموضوع
مهم يعني واذا دخل على طول اول ابتدائي ش
الفرق طبعا انا اقدر اتكلم لك بلغه ارقام
على نسبه نجاح الناس ونسبه رسوب الناس
اللي يروحون رياض الاطفال هذه من الدول
اللي استثمرت ارقام كبيره يعني وصلت 80
90% هذا واحد اين هذه اول مرحله تاسيسيه
يعني احنا اليوم سنه اولى ابتدائي للي ما
دخل رياض اطفال انت قاعد تحاول تاسس فيه
كل شيء ارقام حروف
ويعني باشياء بسيطه زملاء المفروض اللي
دخلوا في رياضه الاطفال حصلوا عليها ف هي
مرحله استثمار مبكر تجهز الناس انه يبدون
فعلا يحققون اهداف مرحله وهي تبدا من عمر
كم من ثلاث سنوات تبدا من ثلاث سنوات
المفروض انتم توصون انه ثلاث سنوات الطفل
يبدا يلتحق بالمدرسه يعني هذا المثالي انه
من ثلاث سنوات احنا النسب احنا نقيس ترى
من ثلاث سنوات ثلاثه الى قبل ست سنوات هذا
هذا يعني العينه اللي احنا نشوفها ونقيس
ادائنا عليها وما دامنا في هذا التحدي قبل
ما تنتق التحديات الاخرى عشان الخص احنا
كنا 16%
فقط المتوسط العالي من 80% وصلنا اليوم
34% صحيح لفت نظري بعض الدول نسبه التحاق
الاطفال في رياض الاطفال
109% 110% شلون جايبين اطفال من جيران
شلون لا هذه يصير يعني في ناس تجاوزوا
العمر المفروض انهم اليوم في المرحله
الابتدائيه لكنه مازالوا في مقاعد رياض
الله تعال تعرف اللي انورد في الشهر
الفلاني صار عمره اكثر من ست سنوات لانه
يقيسون الدول من ثلاث الى ما قبل ست سنوات
طيب اللي مولود في ديسمبر والدراسه تبدا
في اوجست و ما
دخل المرحله الابتدائيه فهو محسوب على
البول حق زي المانيا زي المملكه المتحده
هذول يصلين مرحله انهم غطوا 100% صحيح
وزياده ترى مو بشرط ابو عبد الرحمن انه
100% هم جابوا 109 لانه عندهم مجموعه
المفروض انهم الان في سن المرحله
الابتدائيه بس ما دخلوا اساس الكالندر
وممكن ترى يكون في ناس في الفئه المستهدفه
ما دخلوا بس عدد الناس الاوت لايرز هذول
اللي يعني يرفعون النسبه يكون اكبر بس
عموما الدول هذه متجاوز 90% معظمها وهذا
مستهدف ن احنا في 20 30 نوصل 90 بال هذا
تحدي لاحظتوه تحدي
اخر التحدي الثاني كان في جوده التعليم
يعني يعني نتكلم ك اداءنا في الاختبارات
التعليميه الدوليه كان
مستوى النتائج طلاب المملكه يعني متواضع
جدا ما يليق
جوده ما يليق بالاستثمار ولا حتى اللي
قاعدين نشوفه يعني وهذا يعني لما تشوف
مثلا اختبارات الدوليه اللي تطلع من الاو
اي سي دي وغيرها ادائنا منخفض مقارنه
بالدول اللي احنا نقارن نفسنا
فيها طبعا اتكلم دول مجموعه الع
والدول اقتصاداتها مثل اقتصاد المملكه
يعني ففرحنا شفنا مو متدني احنا من الاخر
صح من الاقل في العالم لا يعني احنا يعني
اقل من المتوسط بس ما احنا بالمراتب
الاخيره يعني على بين مجموعه الع احنا من
المراتب الاخيره صحيح يعني ما احنا
بالاخير ح هي اصلا مو كل الدول تدخل فيها
يعني مجموعه الع تقريبا في 13 دوله تدخل
فاحنا بعد العشره فبعد العش من 13 يعني بس
انا اتكلم على كل الدول اللي تدخل يدخل
تقريبا 80 دوله احنا تلقانا دائما ترتيبنا
من ال 50 ل 65 بالرينج بالرينج هذا في
النصف الاسفل من القائمه بالضبط دون دون
المتوسط وهذا يعني طبعا ما اخفيك رحنا
نسال ليه لقينا في ثلاث يمكن اسباب رئيسيه
واحد اصلا ما في اهتمام
بالاختبار تعرف الطلاب والطالبات في نجاح
رسوب في درجه هذا الاختبار لا ما ما كان
في اهتمام ولا اعطي حجمه فما كان في تهيئه
مناسبه هذا واحد
اثنين ما كنا اصلا نختبر نفسنا بشكل دوري
اختباراتنا
المحليه طبعا كل الدول يصير عندهم اختبار
دولي واختبار محلي ناشن كنا اختباراتنا
الدوليه نسويها كل ثلاث سنوات ونسويها على
عينات فهذا
كان التحدي الثاني ثلاثه احيانا اللغه حق
الاختبار ما هي
مفهومه احيانا لانه تعرف منظمات دوليه
واحيانا فعلا يصير في مشكله اصلا في في
لغه الاختبار يعني هذذه الثلاث اشياء احنا
رحنا حاولنا نضع يعني حلول لها بدينا نسوي
اختبارات وطنيه العام صار على مستوى كل
الطلاب طبعا طبعا اختبارات الدوليه تحدد
مراحل معينه يعني مثلا بزا يختبر اللي
عمرهم 15 سنه الاختبار
التمز يختبر اللي في خامس ابتدائي وفي
ثاني متوسط احنا اختباراتنا الوطنيه كانت
تقام كل ثلاث سنوات اليوم صارت سنويه كانت
تاخذ نفس المراحل اللي ياخذها تمز اليوم
اخذنا مراحل مختلفه عشان يكون
عندنا يعني بيانات اكثر تمكنا نعرف وين
وين فرص التحسين عندنا فالعام صار اختبار
نافس يعني بشراكه بين وزاره التعليم وهيئه
تقويم التعليم اختبروا اكثر من مليون
طالب في مرحله ثالث ابتدائي سادس ابتدائي
وثالث متوسط
والاختبار اخذ حقه تهيئه الطالب عارف ان
هذا الاختبار مهم المعلمين والمدرسه
عارفين ان هذا الاختبار مهم يعطينا يعني
انعكاس
لمستوى جوده التعليم عندنا وصار عندنا
اليوم بيانات نقدر نقدر نعرف وين الفجوات
وين التحديات اللي
نحتاج نعمل عليها
وبنفس الوقت نعرف نق نقاط الضعف وين هل
احنا عندنا تحدي في الرياضيات ولا في
القراءه هل تحدينا اصلا في التاسيس في
مرحله الابتدائي ولا في مرحله المتوسط هذه
البيانات اتيحت اليوم لدارات التعليم
للمدارس لوزاره التعليم كل كل اداره عندها
الاطلاع يقدرون يقيمون المدرسه كيف كيف
اداها
وتتفاجا يعني نلاقي
مدارس بعضها حتى يعني ايذر في منطقه يعني
ما هي منطقه يعني رئيسيه في مدن محافظات
وما عندها يعني المقومات
اللي تخليها تقول هذه مدرسه متميزه بسبب
جوده المعلمين اللي فيها ارقامهم تكون مره
ممتازه يعني شيء شي يعني صراحه يلفت
الانتباه نروح نشوف كيف هذا الجماعه سو
فتلقى اخلاص المعلمين اللي موجودين فيها
والمعلمات اللي موجودين فيها وحرصهم
واهتمامهم صار لا اثر واضح على
جوده طلابهم وبكل امانه يعني المعلمين
والمعلمات ترى هم راس حربه في في التعليم
العام التحدي
الثالث كان هنا ما علمت لوين وصلنا مجلها
انت ولا ولا ما بعد سوينا شيء كويس فيها
الا اشتغلنا اليوم عندنا ديتا صار في
نتائج اخر دورتين في الاختبارات الدوليه
فيها تقدم كل الدول انخفضت بسبب الجائحه
احنا من الدول الوحيده اللي كان عن عندنا
يعني نمو ممتاز وخصوصا في الرياضيات واللي
فاجانا طبعا الاختبارات هذه دائما
الطالبات عندنا في المملكه اداهم افضل من
الطلاب لاول مره في الاختبارات هذه الطلاب
يتجاوزون الطالبات في الرياضيات طبعا
الطالبات احنا عرفنا السبب وش السبب
انه ليش اداء الطالبات افضل واحده من اهم
الاسباب جوده المعلمات يعني اليوم
مهنه التعليم
ماحب المهنه الاولى
للشباب يعني
ل تخرج من بتدخل الجامعه عندك فرص كثيره
متاحه في السابق فتختار تروح هندسه ولا
تخصصات ثانيه لما تخرج عندك فرض فرص كثيره
في سوق العمل ال سنه الماضيه كان في
تحديات في الفرص المتاحه للسيدات فكانت
مهنه التعليم من المهن
يعني المفضله فكان افضل خريجات الجامعه
افضل ما ننتج احنا من قدراتنا البشريه
النسائيه تروح للتعليم هذا انعكس على
اداء الطالبات يعني احنا اليوم قاعدين
نحاول نتاكد
انه كل من يصل لهال المنه هذه يكون من
افضل
منتجات يعني مؤسساتنا التعليم ومتى كانت
اخر دوره
قياس طبعا تم الاختبار في 20
22 في ديسمبر واعلنت نتائجه في 20 23 في
ديسمبر كذلك وكنا في القراءه في الكتابه
في الحساب كلها ارقامنا احسن في القراءه
بس كان فيه يعني انخفاض واعتقد بسبب
التعليم كان عن بعد وهذا الدول الثانيه
صار في انخفاض في كل في كل نسبها ما في
اعتقد الا كان كوريا واليابان اللي حافظوا
على مراكزهم بقيه الدول كلها كان تاثير
سلبي كبير انا اتكلم على كل الدول تدخل
فيه تقريبا حول 70 80 دوله اتكلم على
المانيا على كندا على امريكا في دول اصلا
ما استطاعت انها تسوي اختبار فهذا تحدي
ثاني واخذنا لمحه عن كيف تعاملت معه ش في
تحديات اخرى لاحظتها في المسح
التحدي
الثالث استشراف ن الاحتياجات سوق العمل
وهذا صداع هذا احنا
يعني كنا معظم اجراءات نتخذها رده فعل
انا دائما اضرب المثال هذا اقول في اشياء
صارت عندنا في السعوديه ما عرفنا لها
تفسير اتذكر عبد الرحمن اول ما بدات كباين
الاتصالات امت السعوديه انا ابو عبد
الرحمن عمر عبد الرحمن يعني يقدم برنامج
اخر برنامج ما هو جيد ولا احد يتابعه ولا
احد يشوفه فذا تذكر اب عبد الرحمن كماان
الاتصالات
كانت تعبت سعوديين ما احنا عارفين ليش
بعدين جت مقاهي الانترنت طبعا انقرضت
الكباين جت مقاهي
الانترنت سبب ولاخر كان اللي يشغلونها
سعوديين ما احنا نعرف
زين كان في حاجه في التعليم وتوسع في
التعليم كل الناس راحت التعليم لين
تفاجانا انه عندنا فائض في التعليم كان في
حاجه في القطاع الصحي وتوسعنا والقطاع
الاهلي توسع معنا في القطاع الصحي وبعدين
تفاجانا ان في بعض التخصصات عندنا فائض
فيها واليوم نعرف انه في تخصصات بناء على
الديت اللي موجوده راح يكون فيها فائض في
السنوات القادمه فكان عملنا رده فعل لما
يصير عندي فائض صير عندي مشكله عدم حصول
خريجين على فرص توظيف ارجع اتخذ اجراءات
تصحيحيه اليوم هذا كان الم
وتحدي وضعنا له يعني علاج واضح اليوم
عندنا ثلاث اشياء تساعدنا
على نتعامل مع مع الالم هذا عندنا وحده
اسراف العرض والطلب في سوق العمل في وزاره
الموارد البشريه اليوم
محتضنه قاعدين يشوفون شش نمو سوق العمل
ش الوظائف المتوقع انها تخلق سواء من خلال
المشاريع الكبيره سواء مشاريع الرؤيه او
او غيرها او النمو الطبيعي للانشطه بناء
على المتوسطات النمو السابقه وتنبؤات يعني
الاقتصاد والنمو اللي قاعد يصير عالميا
فصار عندنا وضوح كم احنا نتوقع نمو سوق
العمل ووين بيكون النمو هذا ش
مستوى الوظائف وبنفس الوقت رحنا شفنا
البايب لاين كم اليوم خط الانتاج حقنا كم
عندي بالضبط الجامعات التدريب التقني كم
عندي انا ناس
اليوم في مرحله التعليم بعد الثانوي ومتى
السنوات المتوقع
تخرجهم وكيف هم قاعدين يتوائم مع التنبؤ
حقي كيف
انا اسوي مقارنه بين خط الانتاج اللي هو
العرض اللي بيطلع والطلب اللي انا قاعد
اتنبه فيه واتوقع ولقينا فيه في تحديات
وضع لكثير منها حلول بس ترى هذه مشكله
عالميه ولا ما في ترى ما في ماجك ستك ما
في حل سح
يبي حلها احنا اليوم جالسين نكون استباقي
بدل ردود الفعل اللي كانت في السابق في
قرارات كثيره كانت تبنى كردود فعل اليوم
عندنا امكانيات من البيانات
ومن المعلومات
ووضوح الرؤيه يساعدنا على
ان ندير هالعمليه هذه بشكل بشكل
افضل
هذه من اهم مواضيع الحلقه بلا شك فودي اني
يعني استاذنك اني استفيض فيها شوي يمكن من
اكثر الاسئله اللي تجيني على سناب شات هي
اسئله بعض الاصدقاء اللي من حسن ظنهم يبون
المشوره يبون الراي انا طالب في الثانوي
ولدي في الثانوي قل لي ش التخصصات انا ما
ابغى اكون عب على الاقتصاد ما ابغى اتخرج
واكون عاطل بس اطني معلومه وانا بروح اتخذ
الان قرار مهم في حياتي اني اختار التخصص
اللي عندي فيه فرص افضل ما يلقون جواب ما
في بيانات هذه البيانات لو اليوم قدمت
لهذا لهذا الجمهور انت ممكن تريح نفسك
وتريحهم من معاناه ح تنتج عن انه اختار
خيار وتخرج واكتشف انه م له فرص يعني على
سبيل المثال وصحح ل المعلومه هذه م صحيحه
من المعلومات الصادمه بالنسبه لي انه عدد
لا باس به من العاطلين او الباحثين عن عمل
هم خريجين
القانون طيب اذا هذا التخصص ما في كميه
وظائف كافيه فيه في سوق العا او احتياج
كافي الجمعات لسه قاعده تضخ خريجين في هذا
من هذا القطاع شباب وبنات اليوم في
الثانوي قاعدين يختارون هذا الخيار ويتخصص
فيه ويقضون خمس سنوات من اعمارهم ولو
عرفوا هالمعلومه بانه هذا التخصص ضمن اكثر
ثلاث
تخصصات للباحثين عن عمل او العاطلين قد
ينتج عنه قرار مختلف وتبدا شويه المعادله
تتغير سواء الجامعات تبدا تقلل القبول او
الاشخاص اللي مندفعين على هذا التخصص
يبدون يفكرون فيه اكثر من مره مثل هذه
المعلومات ليش ما هي بمشاركه مع الناس
واضح
طبعا
اليوم يعني انا بجاوب على نقطتين اخوي عبد
الرحمن النقطه الاولى المعلومات ما هي ما
هي متاحه
ا فيه اليوم تقارير تنشر
من المرصد الوطني لسوق العمل وتعطي على
اتجاهات سوق العمل ش
معدلات التوظيف وكذلك على مستوى الجامعات
وعلى مستوى الكليات فهي موجوده بس ما هي
الى الان ما وصلنا على مستوى البرنامج هذا
المفروض ان ن بس مو بهذا بس ترى الهدف
يعني
اليوم نشر البيانات مهمان النا هذا اضعف
الايمان اللي اهم منها انك بتاخذ المعلومه
وتروح تقعد مع الجامعات تحولها الى هذا
موجود هذا اليوم
الجامعات مو احنا ط عمرك اللي يسويها مرصد
المرصد الوطني لسوق العمل بالتعاون طبعا
مع هي البيانات الذكاء الاصطناعي الديت
موجوده الجامعات اليوم يعرفون معدلات
التوظيف ل خريجين برامجهم احنا لما نجي بس
على التخصصات اح في جانبين لازم نفهم
الجانب الاول جانب الكميه كميه الخريجين
كم احد قاعد يتخرج والجانب الثاني جانب
النوعيه الجوده احنا نحاول نحل التحدي هذا
احيانا التحدي في في الكميه واحيانا في
النوعيه او
المخرج اليوم في
جهات بعض الجهات المهنيه قاعده تنشر
بياناتها زي مثلا في التخصصات الصحيه ما
عندنا اشكاليه فيه ليش لانه واضح اليوم
الطلب وين و وهيئه تخصصات الصحيه
تنشر المعدلات مثلا الناس اللي اجتازوا
الاختبارات المهنيه اختبارات الرخصه
الصحيه على حسب الجامعه وعلى حسب البرنامج
هذا
عالجني النوعيه وعالج لي الكميه انه هذا
الاحتياج اللي موجود في في القطاع الصحي
البيانات اللي تنشر من من من الوزاره
الشيء الثاني اليوم كان في تحدي كبير في
بيانات قراءه مستقبل سوق العمل ماهل طبعا
يعني اليوم حتى في تقارير دوليه تصدر الوف
يطلع تقرير كل سنه ولو تشوف تقاريره تلاقي
احيانا فيها فيها
اختلافات ولا اعتقد في دوله اليوم عندها
هال النمو الاقتصادي اللي موجود عندنا
كمشاريع
وفرص فرص س طبعا ترى اليوم احنا انا اي
احد يكلمني يجيني اتصالات زي اتصالات جيك
ابو عبد الرحمن و الجواب الجواب انه ما في
تخصص زين وانت ايش تبي انت وين شغف
انت ش الشيء اللي تستمتع فيه لانه قرارك
هذا يحدد يعني بشكل كبير مستقبلك بال 30
سنه اللي بعدها ف شفت ناس كثير درسوا طب
وجلسوا بسبب ايذر ضغط مجتمعي ولانه قالوا
له هذا التخصص الممتاز وقعد سبع سنوات
يدرس طب بعدين قال انا في المكان
الخطا وشفت ناس دخلوا برضه هندسه بسبب ضغط
مجتمعي وقعد عشر سنوات ما تخرج و تخرج
اشتغل في قطاع اخر
ف اليوم اللي احنا قاعدين نسويه واحد انه
انت لازم تعرف نفسك وتعرف شغفك ش الشيء
اللي يحرك ش الشيء اللي انت كويس فيه هذا
واحد اثنين لا تعتمد على مهاره واحده
اليوم في تغيير كبير قاعد يصير في
الجامعات على اللي هو تعدد المهارات الدبل
ميجر اكثر من تخصص وهذا اعلن من السنه هذه
بدا تقدر تاخذ اكثر من تخصص اذا تقول انا
والله الى الان صوره ما هي ب واضحه مو
بغلط اجلس مع الناس اسمع انا دائما اقول
تخيل نفسك بعد خمس سنوات طالع من هالمكان
هذا لما يجيني احد يقوللي مثلا انا والله
افكر بالقطاع الصحي يقول هذا قطاع نبيل
جدا بس انت فكر بعد السبع سنوات اللي
بتدرسها هل تشوف نفسك في مستشفى وتعالج
مرضا
وهل هذا الشيء يحرك ولا هذا ما هو ما هو
بمناسب لك في ناس كثيره بالعكس هذا شيء
عمل نبيل ومميز وخدمه الناس وال يعني
العمل على رعايتهم يعني ش وه تجي اهميه
موضوع المهارات زي ما
تفضلت والمعارف الاضافيه انه يعني انا
دائما انصح بعض اصدقائي اللي اللي في تخصص
القانون ومثلا مازال يبحث عن عمل وما لقى
الفرصه المناسبه اقول لو اضفت لهذا
القانون تاسيس ممتاز لفهم الانظمه وفهم
اللوائح لكن لو اضفت لها مثلا طبقه من فهم
الحوكمه وامانه مجالس الاداره هذا اليوم
الخمس سنوات اللي فاتت والخمس سنوات
الجايه ما في كلمه يعني سمعناها في
السعوديه اكثر من
حوكمه طرح الشركات في الاسواق الماليه كل
شركه قاعد تحول من ذات مسيه محدوده الى
شركه مساهمه عامه ملزمه انه يكون عندها
امين وهذا الامين لمجلس
الاداره يعني غالبا غالبا خلف القانونيه
بيكون هو افضل مرشح اذا كان ملم بدور
الامانه واللوائح ومتطلبات هيئه السوق
والى اخره فا اضافه مهارات على التخصص
الاساسي ممكن تفرق كثير في فتح الابواب بس
انا برجع لنقطه الشغف اليوم التحدي مو
باني انا ابغى اختار شي يناسب شغفي التحدي
ان اعرف شو شغفي هل في مبادرات في
البرنامج تعالج هذه النقطه اي بدينا موضوع
التوجيه والارشاد من مراحل مبكره اليوم في
الثانوي طبعا شراكه بين وزاره التعليم
ووزاره المارده البشريه وصندوق الموارد
البشريه هدف فيه خدمه ارشاد
مهني هذا التخصص ترى هذه الفرص الوظيفيه
اللي فيه هذه الاشياء اللي ممكن تكون
موجوده بس انا ودي برضه اعلق على موضوع
القانون وو عبد الرحمن كلامك 100% على
موضوع الحوكمه والفرص اللي موجوده فيها
وعشان ما اكون رميت معلومه غلط سالفه انهم
هم ضمن اعلى ثلاث تخصصات باحثين عن صحيحه
هذه مصدرها وزاره المواد البشريه هم اللي
يعطون انا اعرف انه في عندنا يعني تربيه
الاسلاميه لغه عربيه والمحاماه انا اعرف
انه طعمك فيه يعني اوفر سبلاي احنا نسميه
في تخصص القانون ونتكلم على حتى مو بس
الخريجين نتكلم على البايب لاين كامل على
اليوم الناس اللي في مراحل الدراسه بس انه
في جانب ثاني ترى هنا ابو عبد
الرحمن واحده من التحديات اللي موجوده
عندنا في القانون انه هو ترى منتجين عندنا
في المملكه قانون تجاري وقانون شرعي شريعه
يعني بس ترى في فرص ضخمه احنا قاعدين
نستورد او نستقطب مهارات من برا لانه
نحتاج قانون بيئي وقانون ملكيه فكريه
وقانون استثمار ملائكي ويعني اليوم حتى
يمكن او الاستثمار الجريء هذا يعني شركات
الاشات القانونيه الاجنبيه كد خير من
ورانا عقود تحويل قرض الى اسهم ومادري ايش
واسهم برنامج اسهم الموظفين وهذه كلها
نادر جدا تلقى مكتب محاماه محلي عنده
مختصين فاهمين ومتمكن من هذا الجانب وهذا
اللي انصح انا فيه حتى يعني الناس اللي في
المجالات هذه شوف السوق يعني اليوم احنا
عندنا يعني نستورد
ونستقبل انه لانه في حاجه واعتقد
معالي ياسر رميان في لقاء معك قال قال
احنا اذا عندنا قدرات مناسبه بناخذ اذا ما
عندنا ب نجي من بره عندنا بزنس نحتاج اننا
نشغله فاليوم يعني مهم انه حتى الشخص لما
يكون يعني يدرس يشوف ش افق المجال حقه ش
وين الفرص وين يبغى يتخصص وارجع الشي اللي
برضه يعني يحركه لانه
يعني مرحله الجامعه بتع
وبتطلع وبعدين هذه بتشكل مستقبلك 30 سنه
الجايه انك تكون عارف انت ش تبغى ومحدد
توجهك بدون تاثيرات بس خوف ابدان انه كل
شي انت قاعد ترميه على الناس انت دور شغفك
انت راح ابحث عن الفرص انت اعرف ش الجديد
بس انا ما اعرف انا ما احتاج احد يساعدني
مين اللي بيمسك يدي ويخليني اعرف ش شغفي
ثم يخليني اعرف ش المستجدات اللي صارت في
السوق ش المهارات اللي احتاجها واضح ماني
برمي على الناس قلت فيه اليوم اب عبد
الرحمن في اليوم مبادره حق التوجيه
والارشاد ش هذه لو تسولف عنها اك هذه هذ
حده من مبادرات انتم صحيح هذه هذه اليوم
طبعا التوجيه والارشاد هو كوتشين ومنتر شب
يعني خدمه عند صندوق الموارد البشريه
هدف فيها خبراء توظيف يعطونك ش مستقبل
الوظيفه هذه ش الفرص اللي موجوده فيها وين
توجهها ش طبيعه عملها واش المهارات اللي
تتطلبها هال المنه هذه هذا واحد اثنين ترى
في عمل كثير
اليوم
قائم خارج الحكومه كذلك يعني في بروجكت
1932 اللي سووه الشباب عبد الرحمن طربزون
والفريق عمل مميز ممتاز وفي قمم اللي سووه
برضو مجموعه مع مع ماكنزي ممتاز هذه كلها
ترى برامج وفي على مستوى حتى كونتيز اخرى
تلاقي فيها البرامج هذه انه الناس تقدر
تعمل
وفي يمكن تطوع بخبرتك العمل اللي سووه
يعني الزملاء في وزاره الموارد البشريه
والتنميه الاجتماعيه يجيبون الشباب هذول
تعال اجلس مع ناس متخذين قرار وفي اليوم
حتى داخل منصه التطوع تقدر تطوع انك تقدم
يعني توجيه وارشاد للناس فهي موجوده بس هي
الاساس انت لو جيتني وانت اصلا ما ما
اجتهدت ما اقدر افيدك يعني اذا انت ما انت
محضر و
جاي وعندك المعلومات الاساسيه ما اشتغلت
على نفسك ما في احد يقدر يفيدك عشان كذا
انا اقول دائما انها تبدا من الفرد نفسه
هو يعرف نفسه يعرف شش يبغى يعرف ش
المهارات اللي عنده يعرف نقاط قوته وبناء
عليها تسال الناس هذول يضيفون على العمل
اللي انت اسسته
وبنيته البنيه هذه وبعدين تبدا تتضح عندك
الصوره بشكل بشكل وما زلنا احنا في تحدي
الفجوه بين مخرجات التعليم وسوق العمل
وهذه مره مهمه لانها تكد تكون المبادره
الوحيده الواضحه في وثيقه الرؤيه الاساسيه
يعني لما صدرت وثيقه الرؤيه كانت من
الماخذ او الملاحظات ان ما في شيء واضح في
خصوص التعليم باستثناء هذه وهي بحسب كلام
مع الدكتور فهد في حلقته انها هذه جامعه
للمشروع الاساسي في انك انت تعليم الناس
هو ليس غايه هو وسيله انك انت تجهزه
للحياه والتحدي انه هو صاير مشكله عالميه
صحيح التعليم يتغير ببطء وسوق العمل يتغير
بسرعه فانت تلاقي وظائف طلعت وظائف انتهت
في سنوات قصيره وقطاع التعليم لسه مو ب
مستوعب انه ما عاد احتاج هذا واحتاج هذا
او العكس صحيح فهنا ودي اسمع منك اكثر على
ش اهم مبادرات في ردم الفجوه بين مخرجات
التعليم وبين سوق العمل ممتاز طبعا اول
شيء استشراف سوق العمل ان يكون عندنا وهذه
اللي قلنا عنها الوحده اللي موجوده في
الوزاره بالضبط ثاني شيء اليوم مخرجاتها
معلنه ولا لسه قريبا ان شاء الله اوكي اي
ثاني شيء
اليوم الجامعات نفسها صار عندها برضه ديت
وضوح على معدلات توظيف خريجين
على متوسط رواتبهم صار تعطيهم مؤشرات
وصاروا اقرب لقطاع التوظيف ثالث شيء صار
في حتى شراكات بين الجامعات وبين جهات
التوظيف هم يكونون جزء من
تطوير البرامج يعني انت كنت ابو ابو عبد
الرحمن في الزياره اللي كانت معالي وزير
الصناعه في جامعه الكفات البترول برنامج
لهندسه التعدين شراكه بين الجامعه وبين
بين معادن في اعمال مشابهه كثير قاعده تتم
في مجالات اخرى مو شرط ان البرنامج يكون
كله يعني مصمم لجهه توظيف واحده لكن خبرات
جهه التوظيف هذه تساعد في تطوير البرامج
وتعطي
يعني يعني تغذيه راجعه لل المؤسسات
الاكاديميه في التدريب التقني والمهني صار
في تركيز على الشركات وقصه نجاح يمكن ما
اخذت حقها ابو عبد الرحمن هذه انت وثقت
جزء منها في رحله
وعد عننا برضو حلقه مع معالي الفيد تكلم
على موضوع المعاهد الشراكات بشكل مقتضب بس
انه زي ما تفضلت هي قصه يعني لم تعطى حق
يعني اليوم عندنا معهد اللي هو اكاديميه
الطيران صيانه الطائرات فيها سعوديه يسوون
صيانه كل الطائرات اللي تشوفها عندنا
يقبلون اعتقد 800 الى 1200 بالسنه على حسب
الحاجه الجهات الموظفه التقديم
فوق 70 80 80 الف وفي زيها كثير اكاديميات
الحفر مع مع مع رامكو
وشركات الاستخراج النفط
و والكثير في قطاعات السياحه وغيرها يعني
فهذا كله يعني اعمال صارت الهدف منها
اننا
يعني نقلل من الفجوه اللي اليوم موجوده بس
ترى يعني يعني حتى في في دول العالم ابو
ابو عبد الرحمن الجامعات ترى ما هي الهدف
الاساسي فقط العمل يعني حتى يمكن نشتغل مع
ناس كثير تلاقيه اليوم متخرج دارس كيمياء
ويشتغل في شركه استشاريه لانه بعض المهن
تتطلب بس مهارات شخصيه ومهارات تحليليه و
ويعني
وقدرات ما هي في التخصص ما عاد اليوم
الهدف المعلومه اللي تاخذها من الجامعه
الهدف اليوم انت مهاراتك شخصيتك قدرتك على
التحليل عشان كده لما تشوف الشركات
الاستشاريه يهمهم الجامعه اللي انت درست
فيها هل الجامعه فعلا جالسه تبني فيك
هالشخصيه هذه والمهارات هذه مهاراتك
التحليليه بغض النظر عن انت ش درست ش ش
تخصصك ولا يمكن في يوم من الايام نجي نقول
انه احنا
بنقفل يعني
تخصص التاريخ في جامعه الملك سعود لانه
سوق العمل ما يحتاجه يعني اعتقد انه سوق
العمل بيحتاج ناس عندهم تاريخ يمكن ما
يحتاج الكميه اللي اليوم بعض الجامعات
تقبل فيها بس انه المفروض ان نركز على
النوعيه ونركز حتى على الدراسات العليا
وعلى
الابحاث وغيرها بس ارجع اقول الجامعه هي
مرحله تسقل مهاراتك اكثر من انها تاخذ
معارف تاهل سوق العمل المعادله هذه انتهت
ولعت موجوده واليوم شفنا ناس بدون شهاده
جامعيه اليوم شفنا ناس اسسوا شركات
ملياريه ولا ناس حتى في شركات وصلوا الى
نواب رؤساء تنفيذيين في شركات ضخمه ما
عنده شهاده
جامعيه عنده مهاره وعنده مهارات قياديه
وصلته للمكان هذا ما هي بالشهاده وهنا
يمكن اهم مؤشر يقيس هذا الموضوع هو نسبه
التحاق خريجين التعليم بسوق العمل اي صح
صحيح ش ش الهدف
عندكم وين وصلنا فيه طبعا
هذا في عندنا مؤشرين مؤشر للتدريب التقني
ومؤشر للتعليم الجامعي فاليوم اعتقد وصلنا
32% معدلات توظيف الخريجين خلال ست شهور
يعني احنا اليوم في البرنامج تركيزنا على
الوظائف عاليه المهارات المفروض اللي يطلع
من الجامعه يكون عنده مهارات عاليه تمكنه
من
الوصول لسوق
العمل ونشوفها من من من معيارين اول ما
يتخرج الواحد اذا توظف خلال ست شهور
معناته ان هو عنده المهارات اللي يحتاجها
سوق العمل اذا ما توظف معناته انا احتاج
استثمر في رفع مهاراته او اعاده تاهيله
فعندنا مؤشر ثاني نقيس اللي توظفه خلال
12 شهر وهنا طبعا يشارك معنا هدف ببرامجه
التدريبيه على اساس نقدر يعني يكون فيه
يعني الحاق للناس في في سوق هذا كان خط
الاساس وكم وصلنا فيه اللي هو 12 شهر 12
شهر اعتقد
اليوم كان خط الاساس
تقريبا
حول 52 وصلنا تقريبا
56%
الخريجين التعليم الجامعي كان خط الاساس
بالح النسبه الاولى حول 10ش تقريبا ولما
صار فيه تجويد البيانات وجمع البيانات حتى
الجامعات الاهليه وكذا ارتفعت النسبه
واليوم حققنا فيه اكثر من من
32% التدريب التقني اعلى كذلك التدريب
التقني نستهدف تقريبا 45% في 20 25 احنا
اليوم بالاربعينات تقريبا اللي يتوظفون
خلال ست شهور يعني وهذا طبعا يتم متابعه
المؤشر وتجويده يعني عندنا ترى تحدي ابو
عبد الرحمن
كان في جوده البيانات لانه تتكلم انت عن
تقريبا 40 جامعه وجامعات حكوميه وجامعات
اهليه بياناتها غير مركزيه تعرف الجامعات
مؤسسات مستقله زي اي مكان في العالم عشان
نقدر نجمع البيانات هذه ونضبط جودتها اخذ
الموضوع شوي وقت اليوم الحمد لله عندنا
وضوح في البيانات وهذا كان يعني صراحه عمل
يعني مميز الزملاء في هيئه الهيئه
السعوديه لبيانات الذكاء الاصطناعي ان
قدرنا ان نجمع مصادر بيانات موثوقيتها
عاليه وتعطينا دقه في في المتابعه وتغذيه
راجعه للجامعات سواء الجامعات الحكوميه
وال الجامعات اليه ولو نتجاوز هذا التحدي
تحدي الفجوه بين التعليم وسوق العمل ش في
تحديات اخرى برضه قاعدين تشتغلون عليها
يمكن هذه ثلاثه ابرز التحديات احنا ما بس
ما احنا قاعدين ترى بس نع التحديات احنا
قاعدين نشوف فرص ش الفرص الفرص كثير الفرص
اليوم يعني اب اعطي
مثال يعني
الموهوبين فرصه
ضخمه احنا كان في استثمار رائع من مؤسسه
موهبه في المواهب
العلميه يمكن نجاحات او سجل نجاحات موهبه
في في ايسف يعني يشهد بالشيء هذا بس ترى
فيه فرصه
اكبر في الم المواهب الفنيه في المواهب
الرياضيه اكتشافها من بدري والاستثمار
فيها وهذا صار اليوم مع اكاديميه مهد ومع
العمل اللي تقوم فيه وزاره الثقافه في
المهارات الثقافيه في عمل مميز حتى على
المواهب العلميه ابو عبد الرحمن يعني ايسف
يمكن هذه معلومه مو بالكل يعرفها احنا
مسموح للدول ترى تشارك ب 35 طالب فقط لو
فتح المجال المملكه عندها القدره انها
تشارك بعدد اكبر وتنافس بشكل بشكل اكبر كل
الدول 35 طالب الا الولايات المت المتحده
عندها يعني اعتقد السقف مفتوح فابن لما
يروحون يفوز المركز الاول على العالم هذا
شيء مميز وترى كان في محدوديه
بالكشف الكشف عن الموهوبين واختبارات
الكشف في برضه ما هو كل اللي نكتشفه يتم
تبنيهم ووضعهم في
برامج يعني لاثراء مواهبهم فعندنا اليوم
فرصه قاعدين نشتغل عليها و نتوسع فيها مع
وزاره التعليم مع وزاره الثقافه مع وزاره
الرياضه مع مع موهبه هذا واحد
اثنين مستوى احنا تعليمنا الجامعي
ممتاز عندنا فرصه ان نصدر التعليم هذا انا
تفاجات انه في وده من الجامعات الاهليه
عندها طلاب مبتعثين من حده من دول الخليج
تتكلم على 400 500 طالب م بشوي تفاجات انه
يعني عندنا اكثر من 70 الف ايش ما تقول
اسم الجامعه مادام انه يعني مثال حسن
بالعكس ابرك ساعات يعني جامعه رياض العلم
لطب
الاسنان استقطب الطلاب من الكويت وكانوا
اعتقد مبتعثين من حكومه الكويت وبعضهم
دارسين على حسابهم
الخاص في سنه من السنوات كان عندهم 400
طالب وطالبه من الكويت جايين يدرسون في
طلب عالي على جامعه حفر الباطن من من
الكويت في حتى في الجامعات اللي في في
منطقه مكه المكرمه في طلب من دول في في
افريقيا عندنا اليوم فرصه ممتازه زين انه
تخصصات اليوم احنا
عندنا
يعني
اكتفاء في سوق العمل السعودي اننا نفتحها
للمناطق المجاوره ونبدا نصدر تعليمنا
ونكون احنا مركز لتنميه القدرات البشريه
في في المنطقه وعشان كذا اشتغلنا على
التاشيره التعليميه اعدنا هيكلتها وافق
عليها مجلس الوزراء الحمد لله والان يعني
الجامعات عندها مرونه انها
تستقطب تشيره التعليميه هذه تاشيره زي
التاشيرات الباقيه كان الطالب على كفاله
الجامعه اذا بيسافر لازم يسوي له خروج
وعوده غير مصرح له بالعمل الا في يعني ظهر
ساعات محدوده وفي مرافق الجامعه غير مسموح
له انها هي
يعني يعني يجيب معه اسرته الا بشروط يعني
حدود ضيقه جدا فقعدنا هيكلتها بشكل كامل
استحدث تاشيره جديده كانت هذك التاشيره
الدراسيه حق المناح
استحدث تاشيرتين جديده تاشيره دراسيه
طويله المدى هذا اللي يجون يدرسون فترات
طويله سواء طلاب يدرسون بكالوريوس او حتى
دراسات عليا ماجستير ودكتوراه وعندنا ترى
يعني من طلاب المنح ناس يعني مميزين شيء
يعني انا زرت بعض الجامعات جامعه الملك
سعود وجامعه الملك فهاد البترون المعادن
لقيت طلاب درسات عليا يعني صراحه اشياء
مميزه من الدول المجاوره وفي في طلب عالي
ان الناس تجي تدرس هنا طبعا غير كاوس كاوس
طبعا استثناء يعني التمكين اللي عندها
والفرص البحثيه اللي موجوده عندها فاحنا
اليوم نستهدف ان المملكه تكون صار
تاشيرتين تاشيره دراسه طويله اي وقصيره
مدى هذه شورت تجي كورسز كورسز او حتى احنا
اليوم قاعدين نتوسع في موضوع التبادل
الطلابي اكسينج بروجرام كان اول يصير في
اكسينج من طرف واحد نرسل احنا طلابنا في
محدوديه للطلاب اللي يجون عندنا اليوم لا
في انفتاح في توسع بشكل اكبر انه يكون في
فعلا تبادل طلابي ونرسل طلاب لجامعات
وجونا طلاب من من جامعات دوليه فاحنا
هدفنا اليوم في اننا نكون مركز
ل تنميه القدرات البشريه وللتعليم في
المنطقه ونكون وجهه يعني مميزه عندنا فرص
لاستقطاب
المبدعين متميزين في
المنطقه عندنا كذلك فرص لان نكون او يعني
نتوسع في دورنا في تعليم اللغه العربيه
والدراسات الاسلاميه احنا احنا وجه اليوم
تعليميه عندنا الجامعه الاسلاميه وعندنا
مجمع الملك سلمان للغه العربيه وهذا يمكن
حتى نحتاج اننا نوقف عنده يعني العمل اللي
يقوموا فيه الزملاء في المجمع في وزاره
الثقافه يعني في حلقه سابقه مع معهم
السقراط فض مهتم ممكن يرجع يسمع
ممتاز الشيء الثالث نحتاج برضه نتوسع في
موضوع الدراسات العليا والابحاث اليوم مع
الاستراتيجيه او مع الاولويات الوطنيه
للبحث والتطوير
والابتكار المراكز البحثيه في الجامعات هي
واحده من الممكنات الاساسيه للاستراتيجيه
هذه والبحث العلمي المفروض يكون مجال خصم
ومفتوح
لاستقطاب المواهب والباحثين العالميين
فهذه برضه تاشيره الشورت تيرم تستهدفهم
اللي بيجون فتره معينه كباحث زائر وغيرها
اخر
شيء هذا سيرفس التعليم احنا نبغى نصدر
السيرفس هذه فيها امكانيه انها تكون يعني
دخل اضافي للجامعات سواء الحكوميه او
الاهليه عندنا منتج ممتاز احنا قادرين
نسوقه ونبيعه على الدول المجابره ولو
نتكلم بشكل عام عن
مبادرات برنامج كم مبادره
عندكم طبعا 87 مبادره مبادرات البرنامج كم
منها اللي في المرحله من عمر ثلاث الى 23
لانه احنا قاعدين نتكلم على تعليم مدى
الحياه وكل حديثنا السابق وكل امثلته وكل
هي فقط عن مرحله المدرسه والجامعه فوش
عندنا للاشخاص ما بعد مرحله الجامع واضح
عندنا كثير
اليوم يمكن اهم المبادرات اللي احنا
نسويها للاشخاص اللي ما بعد الجامعه اتاحه
فرص التدريب
ا اليوم مع وزاره الاتصالات صار فيه عمل
مميز ضمن مبادره مهارات
المستقبل
لرفع المهارات واعاده التاهيل اب سكيلينج
وري سكيلينج في تركيز برضه على برضه عمل
على مسرعه مهارات مع عده وزارات مسرعه
مهارات قطاع
في قطاع الصناعه والتعدين في قطاع النقل
والخدمات اللوجستيه في قطاع السياحه شفنا
اليوم احنا احنا اليوم نشتغل مع الجهات
نقول اللي ما عنده استراتيجيه واضحه
لتنميه القدرات البشريه في القطاع احنا
مستعدين نشتغل معها عليها اليوم صار في
استراتيجيات
تنميه يعني قدرات بشريه قطاع هذه تعطي دبث
اكثر وين مستوى المهارات ش الاستثم مار
الامثل اللي نقدر نشتغل عليه وتكون تبني
طبعا على البيانات اللي موجوده في
استراتيجيه القطاع
وبيانات وحده
استشراف العرض والطلب فهذا
واحد اثنين في الاستثمار في السياسات اللي
تمكن الناس من الابتكار رياده الاعمال في
عندنا عده سياسات بعضها اقر وبعضها يعني
في تحت تحت يعني
الاعتماد اول شيء السياسات اللي بتكون في
منظومه البحث والتطوير الابتكار وكيف نمكن
الباحثين انه يكون يعني يعني ذ كرشلا او
يعني يعني يعني يستفيدون من ابحاثهم اللي
تكون في مؤسساتنا الاكاديميه العاملين في
في في سوق العمل شغالين اليوم مع وزاره
الموارد البشريه
على يعني اجازات
استثنائيه للي حاب يطور نفسه يتعلم لتنميه
القدرات او لتعلم مدى الحياه واجازات
استثنائيه رياده الاعمال انا اليوم اعمل
في جهه حكوميه الان الوزاره قاعده تعمل
على الضوابط انه اخذ اجازه مده سنتين ابغى
اجرب في في البزنس هذا وا
ابغى اعمل
في ادرب نفسي واتطور واستثمر في
التعلم مدى الحياه في سياسه كثير برضه على
موضوع التوظيف كيف نتاكد انه صار في
برنامج ا بوردين اول الحكومه ترى ما كان
في برامج لتهيئه الموظف كيف يدخل الجهات
اللي عندها يعني مستوى نضج عالي عندها
البرامج هذه لكن نتكلم برنامج وطني شامل
ما كان موجود سوينا ه البرنامج هذا اي
يكون في وضوح كيف يعني ها د امبورت
الموظفين الجدد عدلنا في سياسه التوظيف
الخدمه المدنيه المفروض انها برض هذه تعلن
قريبا سوينا
حتى
يعني
عمل كبير في
تنظيم وحوكمه المهارات يعني اليوم في
مجالات واضح فيها كيف انا اعترف في مهارتي
انا اروح لهيئه التخصصات الصحيه اخذ رخصه
مهنيه اروح لهيئه المهندسين وهيئه
المحاسبين القانونيين اخذ رخصه في مجالات
ثانيه ما
في طريقه جيده للاعتراف بالمهاره نعمل
اليوم مع وزاره الموارد البشريه على اطار
يطر موضوع المهارات وكيف
احنا نعترف فيها
واشتغلنا كذلك بقياده وزاره الموارد
البشريه على مجالس قطاع تنظم القطاعات هذه
وشراكه بين القطاع العام والخاص والقطاع
غير الربحي عشان نقدر
فعلا نشوف ش مستقبل سوق العمل في في ه
القطاعات هذه وكيف نقدر ننميه واحده من
اهم المخرجات العمل هذا كان
فيه حمله وطنيه للتدريب بقياده وزاره
الموارد البشريه ضمن البرنامج الوطني
لتحفيز الجهات جهات التوظيف على تدريب
موظفينها التزموا اعتقد اخر رقم كان اكثر
من مليون و200 او اكثر فرصه تدريبيه شركات
جت قالت انا اتعهد انه بدرب بثمر في
موظفيني هذا كان واحده من التحديات اللي
لمسناها الاستثمار في في في التدريب موظف
يقعد خمس عش سنوات ما اخذ اي فرصه تدريبيه
اليوم صار جزء من حتى جائزه العمل اللي
كانت قبل اسابيع الشركات اللي استثمرت في
تدريب موظفينها وصار فيه يعني متابعه له
هذه امثله بسي مثال واحد ابي مثال على شيء
تقدمونه لشخص فوق 60 سنه اي اليوم طبعا
المتقاعدين يعني عندهم
خبرات
تراكميه ومتميزه
ويعني يعني لهم دور اساسي في العمليه
الاقتصاديه طبعا فتح جوانب كثيره ل العمل
معهم جزء منها طبعا يمكن الجامعات اليوم
صارت تتعاقد مع هذولا جزء منها نستفيد
منهم في منصه اللي هو التوجيه والارشاد
اللي بتكون مع اللي مع مع مع
هدف
وجزء
اخر التسهيل اللي قاعد يصير
في موضوع
اشراكهم
في يعني سياسات تطوير اللي هو
القدرات البشريه يعني مازال فيه يعني فرص
اكبر لاشراك
لكن يعني الحمد لله بدينا بهال الاتجاه
هذا وقاعدين نواصل العمل فيه يمكن اكثر من
من جهه حكوميه او برنامج لما نحكي معاهم
يذكرون انه احد
اهم مكاسب الرؤيه وبرامج تحقيق رؤيه هو
موضوع العمل الاستراتيجي العمل طويل مدى
العمل الذي لا يتاثر بالاشخاص
فوزير يمشي وزير يجي الاهداف وده هذا
الامر
شوي لاحظنا انه ما هو ما هو متحقق في
واحده من
اعمالكم اذا انا فاهم غلط صححي موضوع
الفصول الثلاثه الفصول الدراسيه الثلاثه
احدثت جدل كبير انا بالنسبه لي اعتقد ان
الامر قابل للنقاش وما هو باختصاصك هل صح
ولا مو بصح ثلاث فصول دراسيه فمو هنا
بناقش بس انا انا مشكلتي هي في انه اذا
كان قرار استراتيجي
واتخذ شلون اول ما يمشي الوزير اللي اتخذه
نرجع نناقش الموضوع وجامعات تتراجع عنه
ويعلن بانه قيد الدراسه معته شغلنا مو با
استراتيجي صار شغلنا مبني على على على
افراد فودي افهم ش المشكله وا دوركم انتم
وكيف نتطمن انه احنا في هذا القطاع زي
بقيه الدوله العمل استراتيجي وليس هو عمل
مربوط بالاشخاص واضح
طبعا الفصول
الثلاثه عمر
هذا طبعا التقويم الدراسي شغل او عمل
مسؤوليه وزاره التعليم احنا اللي يهمنا في
البرنامج واللي كان جزء من التحديات اللي
شفناها لما
سوينا التحليل للوضع
الراهن كان عدد الايام الدراسيه ش لقيتوا
لقينا انه احنا عندنا العام الدراسي 36
اسبوع منها اربع اسابيع رايحه اختبارات
بقى 32 اسبوع منها اسبوعين قبل الاختبارات
عاده يعني تكون شبه اجازه زين فصف تقريبا
على 150 يوم
دراسي البنش مارك 180 تقريبا الدول اللي
يعني تعليمها جيد هذا
كان التحدي اللي عندنا اللي ناقشناه مع
الوزاره قلنا نبغى حل التحدي
هذا اليوم اعتقد التوجه الفصول الثلاثه
واضح في في التعليم عام ومو بغلط ان نعيد
دراسته ونتاكد انه نطبق بشكل بشكل افضل هل
فيه تراجع عنه او لا هذا احنا ما عندنا
يعني وضوح في في هالموضوع هذا هذا يعني
الوزاره ما رفع شيء للبرنامج او حتى يعني
صار في رجان لمناقشه الموضوع هذا بزنس
برودكت الوزاره
تشتغل تشتغل عليه انا ودي ارجع هنا خطوه
بس عشان
نوضح كيف جت خطه البرنامج وكيف جت المبا
احنا
لما درسنا الوضع الراهن وقيمنا طلعنا
بتحديات واضحه اللي سويناه بعدده احنا
حطينا التوجه احنا هذا وجهتنا احنا نبغى
نوصل الى مواطن منافس عالميه نبغى ناسس صح
نبغى نعد لسوق عمل مستقبلي ونبغى نتيح فرص
تعلم مدى الحياه هذه التحديات اللي عندنا
وهذا التر نورث حقنا وصار فيه ورش عمل مع
الجهات الحكوميه مع القطاع الخاص مع
القطاع غير الربحي هذه تحدياتنا وهذا
التوجه اللي احنا ماشيين فيه
ا نبغاك تكونون جزء من
هال الرحله اللي احنا قاعدين نمشي فيها
وهنا كان في عمل كان في خليه نحل عمل
متواصل من الجهات جانا يمكن اكثر من 500
يعني مبادره ومشروع
من من الجهات واشتغلنا على يعني دمج بعضها
مراجعه بعضها بعضها كان هذا ما يتوافق
اصلا
مع النطاق العمل اللي احنا نشتغل عليه
ومنها طلعت
ه ه الخطه اللي اليوم احنا قاعدين ننفذها
وترى اليوم
الحكومه ف ديناميكيه عاليه حتى لو كان في
شيء قرار اتخذ وتبين بعدين انه في فرصه
لتحسينه وتطويره ما بغلط وبالعكس يعني هذا
يثبت انه في مرونه
وفيه تركيز عالي بس عشان اجاوبك ما ادري
عن التفاصيل ه هل المفروض انه يصير فيه
نتفق نتفق جدا في موضوع المرونه واظن هذه
من اهم
سمات العمل وقياده التغيير في الفتره
الماضيه بس بطبيعه الحال المرونه لها
تطبيقاتها ولها اماكنها قرار استراتيجي زي
فصول دراسيه هذا ما هو ببساطه خلينا نجرب
ما جازنا نغير اعتقد الموضوع اكثر تعقيدا
من مبادرات اخرى او قرارات اخرى
تحتمل المرونه والتجريب بينما شيء زي كذا
احنا بنفترق انه اخذ حقه الكافي من
الدراسه
واتخذ ليبقى على الاقل مده زمنيه الى ان
تتغير الظروف اللي تخذ لاجلها وقتها اقول
راجع بس ان توني مطبقه العام الماضي وجي
اليوم اقول خلينا نراجع ما
مدانا نقيس اثره عشان نقول نبي نراجع فهنا
التحفظ هنا القلق اللي عند مجموعه من
الناس طيب المراجعه ترى على يمكن اللي نشر
مراجع تطبيق الفصول الثلاثه بس
يعني ما يعني انه احنا قاعدين ندرس اننا
نتراجع عن بس في بع الجامعات تراجعت اي
الجامعات ترى اليوم المفروض ان الجامعات
جهات
مستقله اليوم ترى الجامعات من اول عندها
اكثر من تقويم دراسي يا عبد الرحمن ابو
عبد الرحمن عشان ما تزعل انت مره مره يعني
مركز على عبد الرحمن
ايه عندي واحد تى في البرنامج اسم عبد
الرحمن ودائما اركز عليه ما ادري الاسم
يمكن برضو يعني منكد عليه زي عبد الرحمن
اللي عندي منكد عليه ولا غير لا بالعكس
والله ونعم انا كنت بغير اسمي بخليه عبد
الرحمن بس عاد ما ما ضبطت يعني مت ذ وانت
صغير وانا صغير كان عندي عدم قناعه بالاسم
بس اليوم الحمد لله مبسوط
فيه اليوم الجامعات من اول كليه الطب
عندهم كالندر خاص فيهم ر عندهم كالندر خاص
فيهم فالجامعه المفروض انها تطبق اكثر من
من نموذج كان فيه داخل مجلس الجامعات
توافق على تحول الى توسع في تطبيق الفصول
الثلاثه في في الجامعات وبعدين في جامعات
ما طبقت ابد فصل ثلاثه وفي جامعات طبقت
على
برامج معينه
وبعدين في جامعات زي ما تفضلت تراجعت احنا
اللي اللي عندنا في البرنامج واللي كنا
طبعا مجلس الجامعات هو الجهه المنظمه
للتعليم الجامعي اللي عندنا في البرنامج
واللي احنا
يعني يعني كان واضح التوجه وزاره التعليم
فيه واللي هو موضوع التعليم العام الفصول
الثلاثه في التعليم العام اللي يهمنا احنا
جوده التعليم العام وعدد ايام اليوم كم
عند ايام دراسه اليوم اكثر من 180 انت ما
شاء الله يعني جبتوا اقصاك في الموضوع لا
ترى ترى في دول فوق ال
200 دراسي وفي دول 190 بس احنا تكر احنا
انتقلنا من فتره كانت الاجاز صيفيه اربع
شهور وهذا كان يعني غير منطقي ال انه
اجازه اقل من شهرين يعني الصيف الجاي
الظهر الاجازه شهرين الا يوم شهرين الا
يوم فيعني بس توزعت ترى
الاجازه الجاز الصيفيه اي هو طبعا يعني
يعني الدراسات تقول ان المفروض ما يكون في
توقف طويل هذا ابار زين فاليوم تلا تلاقي
بين كل فصل وفصل في اجازه اسبوع اسبوعين
تلاقي احيانا في اجازات في منتصف وهذا
تحسون صحي هذا صحي جدا اه الامهات زعلانين
يقول ما يمدينا نبدا الا وقفته ما يمدينا
يعني نبني حماس الطالب اللي خرب نومه في
اجازته باسبوع فهذه انتم يعني تشوفونها
ممارسه عالميه سليمه الاجازات القصيره
الكثيره هذه شوف في الاجازات القصيره وفي
الاجازات اللي هي منتصف اللي بين الفصول
الاجازات القصيره انه ويكند ما مشكله بس
اتكلم على انت اسبوع هذه فيها فصله فيها
تغير موعد نوم فيها احتماليه انقطاع هي
بين الفصول معظمها يعني لو في منتصف الفصل
هذه يصير فيه في اعتقد اتذكر فصل واحد
يكون في منتصف الفصل هذا كان لانه في
جامعات تمشي على الفصلين كثير وتبغى
الاسره يكون عندهم برضه فرصه انه يكون
اجازه لكل الاسره فالك الفصلين اللي يعتمد
ممتاز يكون في اجازه متقاطعه بين بين هال
الاجازت
هذه تسهل على الناس ان الاسره كلها تكون
تكون مع بعض وما يكون كل سنه في كونفلكت
بين وعلى ط كونفلكت يعني اشوف بعض رسائل
الاصدقاء انه احنا تورطنا في مساله الثلاث
فصول هم في جامعه طبق ثلاث فصول يقول صرنا
نروح نقدم على برامج التدريب التعاوني
ونلاقي ان احنا يا جينا بدري يا جينا
متاخر الشركات ما عاد تبينا خلاص الشركات
مبرمجه نفسها على التدريب التعاوني اللي
هو مبني على
فصلين فلما يجونها طلاب من جامعات ثلاث
فصول يكون ما هو في نفس الباتش او الدفعه
الغالبه فتضيع عليهم فرص كثير في التدريب
التعاوني نتيجه فكره الثلاث فصول دراسيه
في الجامعه حالات زي هذه هل ترصدها
تشتغلون عليها مع الجامعات دوركم في
الموضوع هذا طبعا يعني خلينا ناسس نقطه
هنا ابو عبد الرحمن الجامعات اليوم يعني
اجهزه مستقله عندها المرونه
وال يعني انها تعدل
في حتى في برنامج التدريب يعني هذا هذا
واحد اثنين المفروض الجامعه تكون اقرب
اصلا لجهات التدريب يعني اليوم احنا اللي
قاعدين نقول الجامعات المفروض تكون مبادره
قاعدين نعمل عليها مع الجامعات مجلس
الجامعات ومع هدف ان يكون في مكتب للتوظيف
فيه موجود اليوم في عدد من الجامعات
بالبترول يسمونه بليسمنت سنتر
وفي مكتب خدمات التوظيف في جامعه ملك سعود
هذه المفروض انها معظم الجامعات او كل
الجامعات يكون عندها هذا دوره انه ينسق مع
جهات التوظيف على
مواعيد التدريب تتاح الفرص
التدريب للطلاب احنا اللي طلعناه سياسه
احنا اليوم نقول المفروض ما نعترف
بالتدريب اقل من ست اشهور المفروض اي احد
قبل لا يتخرج من الجامعه يتدرب لمده ست
شهور طبعا في تحدي لانه انت كنت سعه اوطلب
وين ندربهم خصوصا لما اتكلم على بعض
الجامعات اللي يمكن حجم الاقتصاد في
المنطقه اللي فيها ما يتيح فرصه انك تدرب
كل كل طلاب الجامعه فحاولنا اننا ندفع
بالاتجاهين حطينا المستهدف العمل المبكر
على وزاره الموارد البشريه قلنا دورك انك
تتيح فرص والعمل اليوم ترى مو بشرط عمل
فيزيك عمل مرن عن بعد تقدر انت اليوم تاخذ
فرصه تدريبيه كو اب حتى لو ما كان يعني
فيزيكال او يعني بحضور
وعند وزاره التعليم حطينا السياسه وعن مجس
الجامعات انه المفروض تعدل الخطط الدراسيه
ونتاكد انه في خبرات عمليه كافيه وان يكون
في نسبه معينه من الخبرات العمليه ونفترض
انه التوتال يكون ست شهور تدريب وبدا بدل
اليوم تطبيقها في عدد كبير من الجامعات
لكنها اليوم الجامعه مسؤوليتها
انها تتعامل مع جهات التوظيف وتتيح
فرص للتدريب والشركات يعني في مرونه اصلا
في استقبال المدربين يعني احنا انا اشوف
الجهات اللي نعمل معها وحتى عندنا احنا في
البرنامج التدريب يعني مفتوح بشكل بشكل
اكبر مااله يعني مره بالسنه او مرتين
بالسنه انا ودي اختم ب قبل ما اروح لاسئله
الاصدقاء ابغى اختم باهم جزء عندي صراحه
يهمني انا شخصيا موضوع
القيم ش تقدر تسولف عننا ك مستهدفات
مبادرات تحديات وا عندكم في موضوع القيم
طبعا اول شيء احنا يعني مجتمع يعني ولله
الحمد
يعني عندنا قيم مميزه
ومجتمع محافظ على على قيمه وعلى عاداته
يعني احنا نودي ناسس شوي نرجع القيم وين
تجي في اي مجتمع ش مصدر القيم هذه كيف
الناس يكون عندها هال الاعتقاد والايمان
بالقيم هذه وتعمل عليها من يمكن اربع
مصادر رئيسيه الدين الاديان السماويه احنا
عندنا القران والسنه غنيه بالقيم تعلمنا
الصدق والامانه والاخلاص وغيرها من القيم
النبيله اللي موجوده عندنا الموروث
تاريخي يعني والثقافي وهذا يعني احنا
اليوم
كمجتمع
في عمق الجزيره العربيه وموروثنا التاريخي
وابطالنا
يعني اسسوا فينا قيم ممتازه لما نتكلم عن
الكرم عندنا مثل حاتم الطائي
الشجاعه
يعني الملك عبد العزيز والعزيمه اللي وحد
فيها هال المملكه هذه يعني ف موروثنا
التاريخي ثلاثه
حتى الوضع الاقتصادي والاجتماعي تطور
والتقدم اللي اللي اللي نعيشه يجي
بقيم
كذلك اضافيه
الانضباط الاتقان هذه كلها برضه تكون جزء
من
نظام البلد واخر
شيء النظام التعليمي
والاجتماعي كيف احنا ناسس لانه التاسيس
جزء مهم في ه الموضوع ده في عمل كبير على
موضوع القيم هل في قيم محدده احنا
مستهدفين طبعا الرؤيه جت في عده قيم ضمن
اهداف الرؤيه محدده ش القيمه اللي
تستهدفها المجتمع السعودي طبعا ذكرناها في
وثيقه البرنامج الاتقان الانضباط العزيمه
المرونه الايجابيه الانتماء
الوطني الوسطيه والتسامح يعني هذه امثله
على على القيم اللي اللي اللي احنا ن ك
تعزون في الناس طبعا من عده جوانب من
جانب السياسات في سياسات تعزز قيم معينه
الانضباط ترى يصير يعني اتذكر احنا لما
سوينا دراسه على الدول اليابان كان عندهم
ثلاث قيم واذا رحت اليابان
تشوفها اوردر وسبل
و نسيت والله الثالثه زين
فل هو انضباط
وترتيب والنظام ف وتشوفها موجوده يعني وكل
احد
يعني يعني يعيش وهذ بالمصادفه ولا كانت
مشروع وطني مشروع وطني طيب مو بهذا الدرس
ان احنا بدا ما نستهدف 9000 قيمه نركز على
ثلاث ما نستهدف
000 ذكرتهم ت احنا تس ترى احنا احنا
اكسبشن يا احنا كل شي قاعدين
نسويه زين قاعدين نروح روح الابعد الابعد
اذا اذا بنحدو السنا بالطموح اللي موجود
في الدوله الثانيه او بتجاربهم ما وصلنا
شي نصل القيم شيء مره عميق تدخل في تكوين
الانسان وحوافزه
و تؤثر على قراراتها وعلى معتقداتها تتاثر
بالمعتقدات وتؤثر في المعتقدات صحيح فشيء
زي كذا ان تترك اثر على الجيل الجديد وحتى
على الجيل الحالي يتطلب مجهود مكثف ومركز
لين تبدا تكسب قيمه معينه يعني مثلا اليوم
تلاحظ من السمات الواضحه في المجتمع
السعودي هي موضوع الطموح صحيح هذه قيمه
جديده يمكن ما كانت حاضره بنفس هذا الزخم
قبل الرؤيه نبي محمد رفع السقف والجهات
رفعت السقف وكل ما طلع واعلن عن مشروع
نلاقيه يفوق قدرتنا على استيعابه اصلا
فحتى حديث الناس داخل اسرهم داخل شركاتهم
داخل الجهات اللي هم يعملون فيها بدا
الطموح يرتفع متى هذا الشيء صار واح نكلم
على قيمه واحده بعد سبع ثمان سنوات من
الجهد والحديث والاعلام ورفع السقف فانت
تكلم على تسعه متى يعني متى
بديك تحكي عنها و تغرسها وتتابعها وتصلها
في الناس واضح طبعا اول شي خلينا يعني
نتفق انه اصلا احنا مجتمع
قيمنا مختلفه
اتكلم انا
اليوم يعني ثقافه القيم عندنا هذا في كل
مجتمع كل مجتمع له قيمه لا لا بس انا
اتكلم اليوم ارتباطنا والتزامنا بالقيم
مختلف
من من يعني من زمان يعني مشهور ومعروف عن
سكان الجزيره العربيه لان المجتمع
متدين الدين حاضر بقوه ولان مجتمع يغلب
عليه القبيله او القبليه او التكتلات اللي
يصير في فيها ثقافه مشتركه فتبدا انت لازم
تكرم ضيفك لازم تعين فلان
وهو على وجه زواج لازم تعطيه العانيه لازم
تبر بامك
لانه لو ما بريت فيها حت تدخل النار فانت
تبدا تهتم فيها ما توديها دار الجزه
تخليها عندك فاحنا مجتمع متدين وقبلي هذه
اخذت دتين ترى بس بس موروثنا الثقافي
وانجازاتنا هذه قيمه ترى عندنا هذا
اعتزازنا انجازات اللي صارت
واعتزازنا بالشيء اللي اللي صار في
المملكه الله اللي يعزنا ما لحد منه هذه
كل احد يعني يعيش القيمه هذه بس انا بجي
على اح احنا ايش قاعدين نسوي يا س احنا
اليوم في شيء في التعليم تاسس في التعليم
وفي الاسره لازم يكون في انضباط وهنا بد
انا ابغى اشيا محدده بعد اذنك في التعليم
ش سويتوا في التعليم اليوم صار فيه اصلا
مراجعه للمناهج وتوضيح وتعزيز للقيم صار
في مراجعه للسياسات اليوم في يعني لائحه
للسلوك هل تغيرت القصص اللي المكتوبه في
الكتب الامثله اللي في الرياضيات هل تغير
كل
هذا الضخ اللي يصير لان القيم هي اشياء ما
هي مباشره القيم هي اشياء غير مباشر صحيح
اي تغير كثير انا ودي حتى يمكن لو يكون
فيه احد من الفريق اللي عمل على المشروع
هذا كان مشروع مشترك بين وزاره التعليم
واداره الملك عبد العزيز على تاصيل القيم
الوطنيه
في في تعليمنا هذا واحد
اثنين ابراز النماذج الناجحه احنا احنا
قبل لا
نبدا الاطلاق كان واحده من
اهم الاشياء اللي عملنا عليها اعلاميا ان
نبرز النماذج الناجحه ترى خلق النماذج هذه
يعطي فرصه يمكن الكتور هاني نجم احنا اللي
رتبنا له وا استضفنا اول ما يعني ظهر في
في في امبيسي في اسبو لانه قصه يعني تخلق
صراحه يعني طموح عالي و توري الناس انه
فيه في عمل جيد حتى في
توثيق يعني هل ه القصص هذه ونشرها في عمل
مميز مع الزملاء في في وزاره الاعلام
والجهات التابعه لها على حتى رسالتنا
الاعلاميه انها تكون تعزز القيم في
سياساتنا وهذه
يمكن يعني لا في التعليم ولا في حتى سوق
العمل كلها اشياء قاعده تعزز اننا منضبطين
اننا
نتقن عملنا وانه عندنا العزيمه والطموح
اللي مكنا ان نوصل ابعد يعني بنتقل
لمجموعه من اسئله الاصدقاء بعد اذنك واحد
سؤال واضح انه بريء
مره يقول انتم مره مهتمين باللغه العربيه
صحيح مؤتمركم الجاي اللغه الرئيسيه في
العربيه ولا لا لا طبعا اللغه في لغه
عربيه في ترجمه للجلسات الرئيسيه بس احنا
اليوم مؤتمرنا الهدف الاساسي منه اننا
نناقش القضيه هذه مع المجتمع العالمي
اللغه العالميه الانجليزي يمكن في
اربع جلسات راح تكون على على المؤتمر وفور
ستيج يعني الجلسه الرئيسيه بتكون باللغه
الانجليزيه لكن في ترجمه فوريه زين الجلس
الثانيه لانه انا جاي
الهدف الاساسي من استضافه المؤتمر هذا
اننا نناقش التحديات هذه اللي تواجه تنميه
القدرات البشريه في
العالم اذا عندي متحدثين من اسيا ومن
اوروبا ومن افريقيا اللغه المشتركه اللي
تجمعهم اللغه الانجليزيه يعني وهذا ترى
هذا يعني اللي يصير في معظم المؤتمرات
العالميه
يعني في سؤال على موضوع الملف الموحد انت
عندكم مبادره الملف
ملف ملف التعليم الموحد لا يعني انا صارلي
موقف كنت بطلع لولدي هويه ويوم رحت ل
الاحوال يقولون ما نعرفه يعني ما ندري هو
في اي سنه دراسيه اطبع لنا ما ادري ايش
حسيت اني رجعت لسنوات قديمه خلاص الربط
التقني مفترض صرت الحين اذا رحت للداخليه
ما عاد احتاج اجيب معي شيء اول مره احسني
رجعت 20 سنه ورا لما قالي جيب لي تعريف من
المدرسه في اي سنه دراسيه هو ليش ما في
ربط بينهم ليش ما في ملف للطالب في كل
نتائجه في كل معلوماته بكره بدخل الجامعه
بدل ما اشيل الملف العلاقي حقي خلاص خذوا
البيانات من عندكم اي طبعا اللي يهمنا
احنا بالملف الرقمي الموحد انه يكون
معلومات
الطالب الصحيه والنفسيه
والدراسيه تكون موج مكان واحد مكان واحد
يعني اليوم يمكن متكم صحيح واحده الاشياء
اللي سويناها مو هدفنا انه نخدم الحكومه
الالكترونيه مع انه هذا هدف يعني كويس بس
انه مو بهذا مو بهذا الواجب اللي علينا
وانا ما عندي والله فكره ليش اليوم اللي
يعرف انه سدايا عندها كل بيانات الطلاب
يعني موجوده هي ديجيتل فانا استغرب انه
طلب منك العمل هذا لكن اليوم المبادره
اللي ذكرتها ابو عبد
الرحمن احنا حريصين انه زي ما ملفك الطبي
لما تروح من مستشفى لمستشفى المفروض انه
يكون واحد ويعرف كل التاريخ حقك واله
السري والاشياء اللي مريت فيها وهذ اعلن
عنها يعني مؤخرا مع وزير الصحه اعلن عن
برنامج نفيس وانه هو بدايه نواه الملف
الطبي الموحد وفي كل كشفيات وكل تاريخك
المرضي الى اخره احنا نبغى ملفك التعليمي
المفروض انه اسهل هذا شوي
طبعا كل شيء على السيرفس ابو عبد الرحمن
سهل بس انا اتكلم يعني انه يعني اليوم
واحده من الاشياء اللي برضه اشتغلنا عليها
مع وزاره التعليم وهيئه الاشخاص د الاعاقه
موضوع تصنيف الاعاقات اللي عنده صعوبه
تعلم اللي عنده مشاكل اجتماعيه او اسريه
اللي عنده يعني المفروض ان يكون عندك تراك
ريكورد واضح سجل واضح للطالب و ولو انتقل
من مرحله الى مرحله وجا مدرس جديد او
انتقل من مدرسه الى مدرسه المعلم يقدر
يعرف الطالب اللي امامه يقدر يتواصل معه
يقدر يعرف ش
الظروف اللي يعيشه ه الطالب هذا وكيف انا
اقدر اتعامل معه بافضل طريقه هذا كان
هدفنا ما هو بهدفنا تسحيل خدمات الحكوميه
هذا
يقول اسال ابو ابراهيم ليش علاقته متوتره
مع الجهات الحكوميه اللي تنفذ مبادرات في
البرنامج لا بالعكس يعني شوف ما اعتقد انه
توتر
يمكن كيف تصف علاقتك
معهم تكامليه احنا نكمل بعض يمكن احيانا
احنا ترى ابو يعني احنا
البرامج
ماحن
فيذ
انتم للاير او طبقه تنسيقيه فوق الجهات
وتحت لجنه استراتيجيه بالضبط فكم مطلبين
احيانا والجهات احيانا يقولون يعني خفوا
علينا شوي يعني بس العلاقه بالعكس ممتازه
وطيبه هذا احنا نجرح ونداوي هذا السؤال
يقول عندهم قصه رهيبه في موضوع الابتعاث
خليه يقوللك اياها هل عندنا لو لو كذا
بشكل
موجز شيء يستحق في موضوع الابتعاث بكل
سرور الابتعاث جانا توجيهنا ان ندرس يعني
نعد استراتيجيه
للابتعاث وسوينا الحقيقه تحليل ودراسه كل
التجارب السابقه
يعني يعني انا من مخرجات برنامج خادم الح
الابتعاث وافتخر يعني الحمد لله تغيرت
اعطاني فرصه اخذت خبره عمليه اشتغلت لما
كنت ادرس و وجيت عندي مهارات غير المهارات
اللي كانت عندي اساسا سويت كرير شفت على
موضوع الشغف كنت ديفلوبر ابرمج واكتشفت
انه مو بهذا المكان المناسب لي ورحت ركزت
على البزنس وعلى الاستشارات الاداريه فجان
التوجيه ان اننا ندرس الاستراتيجيه
للابتعاث وعملنا الحقيقه عمل تشاركي مع مع
الوزاره
وركزنا على
النوعيه يعني الابتعاث اول ما بدا كان في
تحدي بالطاقه الاستيعابيه بالجامعات ماتب
هذا التحدي يعني كان في حتى بعض
اعضاء اللجنه يقولون هل نحتاج ابتعاث جينا
قلنا ترى المانيا
الصين كندا تبتعث نعم نحتاج ابتعاث نحتاج
تنوع نحتاج جيد اللي صار انه ركزنا على
الجوده والنوعيه برنامج الابتعاث السابق
يمكن كان اقل من 10% اللي راحوا الافضل
200 جامعه اليوم اكثر منل من 10% اللي هم
كم 500 ال طلع اكثر من 500 ال اكثر من 500
ال وهذا لان الهدف كان واللي راحوا لافضل
100 جامعه يتعدون 00000 ا اللي افضل 200
جامعه اي ما يتعدون 00000 هذا في طبعا
اتكلم على العشر سنوات من الابتعاث ترى في
وقتها كان ما هو بغلط استراتيجي لانه كان
عندنا تحدي في الطاقه الاستيعابيه صحيح ما
كان عندنا كميه اليوم طيب ش وضعنا اليوم
مركزين على اربع اشياء مركزين واحد على
النوعيه افضل 30 جامعه يعني انا اعت م
افضل 200 افضل 30 الحين هذا اول اول مسار
سويناه اففضل 30 جامعه هذا ادرس في اي
تخصص
لان نبغى متميزين في كل التخصصات الابتعاث
مضمون اذا جبت قبول من هذولي نعم فورا
فورا يعني توجيه سحظ اذا نحتاج اكثر
علمونا ارجعوا اذا نحتاج نبتعد اكثر فهذا
الافضل 30 جامعه حتى احنا يعني التقديم
تجاوز توقعاتنا كنا نتوقع يعني يجينا 400
بالسنه العام عام 22 حوال ال000 راح اف
جامعه
و2 اعتقد 700 يعني فعندنا اكثر من 1500
طالب اليوم وطالبه يدرسون في افضل 30
جامعه حول العالم انا اتكلم اوفرول انا
اتكلم على ام اي تي هارفرد دييل كولومبيا
الجامعات هذا الرقم كم كان قبل البرنامج
ما كان شي والله ما عندي الرقم بالضبط
يعني لان الجامعات تطلع وتدخل من التصنيف
بس كان اقوللك 550 الف
كل افضل 200 يعني ترى احنا عندنا اليوم
ثلاث جامعات سعوديه ضمن افضل 200 جامعه
المسار الثاني اللي سويناه هذا طبعا
المسار الاول اسمه الرواد المسار الثاني
اللي
سويناه العمل امداد انا استل احتاج ابتعث
على تخصصات في حاجه لتنوع في سوق العمل
وهذه مبنيه على مدخلات وحده الشراف العرض
الطلب الوحده يعني طبعا في حوكمه معينه
لبرنامج الابتعاث في لجان يعني اللي يحدد
وين ن ابتعث لجنه يراسها وزير المال
البشريه
ف حددت الوحده التخصصات وصار في نقاش من ه
اللجنه الوزاريه هذه فيها عدد من من
الاعضاء وهذه تحد حث بشكل دوري ويعني
اقوللك يعني اليوم مثلا من التخصصات اللي
نتوقع انه لها مستقبل مثلا التقنيات
الزراعيه بس ما في تقديم عليه ما في اقبال
دورنا احنا ودور الامانه المعنيه في عن
الابتعاث ان تتكلم مع وزاره البيئه
والمياه والزراعه نقول ترى عندنا فرص في
هالمجال هذا يعني الفضاء مثلا اخذ استثناء
السنه هذه وشفنا اقبال مميز عليه وهذا من
اقتصاديات المستقبل وتوجهات الاستراتيجيه
المسار الثالث البحث والتطوير ما نبي احد
يروح دكتوراه
ودراسات عليا اذا ماه في مجالاتنا
الاولويه عندنا اليوم ترو نورث وجهه واضحه
مجالات ست مجالات الاولويه
وهذه يعني الفصل فيها لمنظومه البحث
وتطوير الابتكار اخر شيء وهذا اول مره
نسويه ابتعاث للتدريب التقني
فاليوم ابتعاث مبتد بالتوظيف
مو بشرط تاخذ شهاده اليوم ف اتفاقيه وقعت
مع لوس مع الصافي دنون مع شركات في في
قطاع التعدين مع شركات في قطاع السياحه
نبت يشتغلون يعني اليوم في سعودين اللي
بيشتغلوني لوس في مصانع لوس في امريكا في
السعوديين اللي يشتغلون في شركات التعدين
اللي بتكون في راس الخير يداومون اليوم في
في كوريا
وفي في اليابان فهذا ما قد صار قبل وميز
انها زي ب اخذنا نموذج برامج الشركات اللي
في التدريب يعني
مبتدئ بالتوظيف وانت تروح تاخذ خبره عمليه
لانه ماد بالشهاده هي على المهاره اللي
عندك والخبره العمليه تجي فيها اب اختم
بسؤال مره مهم بدانا وما نستغني عن خبرتك
وفهمك فيه بكل ما اطلعت عليه من ابحاث
ودراسات وسوق عمل وتوجهات تعليميه اتخيل
كثير من الافراد ومن الاباء
والامهات يتمنون الافضل لعيالهم ويتم تون
انهم يكونون الاجهز والاق على اغتنام
الفرص الهائله اللي الحمد لله بلدنا مقبل
عليها نتكلم على مواطن منافس عالميا لو
بتنصح الشخص اللي بحاول يشتغل على هالنقطه
بنفسه ش اهم الاشياء اللي مفترض ينتبه لها
ش اهم القيم اللي يحاول يكتسبها ش اهم
المهارات الاساسيه او العليا او مهارات
المستقبل اللي المفترض يشتغل عليها طبعا
احنا ما نبغى نقول كل شيء ابي تقول لي
هذول الاثنتين لو اشتغلت عليهم ترى امورك
بتكون زين واضح طبعا اول شيء عندي
يمكن توضيح ش نقصد احنا منافس عالميين ترى
ما هوو بالهدف ان ابنائنا يروحون يشتغلون
من برا اننا اي عمل نقوم فيه يكون في
ستاندرد عالمي زي الاطباء اليوم عندنا على
مستوى عالمي الناس اللي في قطاع الطاقه
والاويل ان جاز على مستوى عالمي فهذا واحد
اثنين عندي
رساله للاباء والامهات يعني
يعني هم الاساس
ركز على شخصيه ابنك
يعني
التاسيس المهارات هذه اللي احنا قاعدين
نقولها من مراحل مبكره هذا شيء ضروري يعني
اعطيك مثال ابو عبد الرحمن انا ما ادري
يعني
كيف عبد الرحمن مساحه اتخاذ القرار عنده
اذا تبغى ولدك يكون عنده مهاره اتخاذ
القرار ديمقراطيه عاليه اذايا متفقين رايه
يمشي اذايا مختلفين رايه يمشي هو يختار
ملابسه يختار اكله
اختار ترفيهه يعني مهاره اتخاذ القرار هذه
المفروض تبداها من سن مبكره سنه سنتين
الطفل تبي الشوز هذا ولا الجزمه هذه ولا
الجزمه هذه تبي الم علمه ازرع فيه اتخاذ
القرار طبعا انا اعطيت مهاره واحده انا
اتكلم على كل المهارات اذا اسست اسستها من
بدري ترى المفروض طفلك يعني مستقبل يكون
انسان مميز زيها مهاره التحليل خليه يفكر
يحلل لا تغششه لا تتخذ
يعني القرارات يعني نيابه عنه
هذه الاباء والامهات لشباب
اليوم ركز على نفسك انت اذا انت ما عرفت
نفسك ما في حد
بيساعدك ما هي بسهله الكلام سهل انا من
الناس اللي كنت في مجال وحولت المجال ثاني
وكان في عمليه يعني
مقاومه اجتماعيه لا الوالد كان يعني متحمس
ولا الوالده ولا حتى الناس اللي حولي لا
في اتخاذ اول شيء وش بدرس ولا بعدين لما
قلت بغير زين كلها كانت يعني مغامرات يعني
او خلينا نقول خيارات استراتيجيه انا كنت
داخليا مقتنع فيها واتخذتها فاعرف انت ش
تبي وابن يعني توجهك عليه ممتاز
انك تاخذ راي وتوجيه
توجيهات واستشاره من الاخرين بس لا تخلي
الاخرين يتخذون قرارك انت الشخص اللي تتخذ
قرارك واليوم الحمد لله الفرص يعني مره
ممتازه اتخذت قرار وانت مقتنع فيه انا حتى
ابو عبد الرحمن يعني زمله يعني حتى عندي
في البرنامج اذا احد يستقيل يجي يقول
بتكلم معك انس كاخ ابي استقيل جايني فرصه
اب اشورك اقول لا بكل بساطه في عاطفه وفي
منطق العاطفه اذا انت مره مبسوطين تقول
انا بقعد واذا انت زعلان على مديرك ولا
زعلان علي العاطفه هذا الغالب صح لكن
بالعكس لكن لو هو زعلان ما جا يكلمني يعني
لكن انا دائما اقول المنطق هو اللي حدد
القرار الصحيح اقوله احط لك اكسل شيت بسيط
حط ش الشيء اللي تبغاه بال الوظيفه انت
العائد المادي مهم حط له وزن واحده من
المعايير حقتك البيئه العمل حط لها
وزن فرص النمو في في هالمجال هذا التعلم
حتى بعض الناس اقول له يا اخي ترى موقع
العمل مهم زن صحيح اذا انت يوميا بتروح 45
دقيقه من وقتك او اكثر يوتنج في مشكله هذا
يعطيك قرار مبني على واقع فهذه هذه ال
نصيحتين اللي يعني ودي اوصلها واذا تسمح
لي انا ودي بعد يعني زي ما انت بتختم انا
ودي اختم اي صراحه اول شي اشكرك
ابو عب الرحمن على اتاحه الفرصه واشكر
الصراحه يعني الفريق العمل اللي في في
البرنامج
يعني مرينا ب يعني منعطفات مره كانت صعبه
شفت منهم الحقيقه كل الدعم والتمكين ونفس
الشيء اصحاب سمو المعالي اعضاء اللجنه
يعني حلمهم وتوجيههم ودعمهم هو اللي وصلنا
وحكمه تمه يوصلنا وين وين احنا فيه وما
زال الطريق ان شاء الله قدامنا اطول باذن
الله عكم على القوه شكرا ابو دان على قبول
الدعوه شكرا الله يحفظك شكرا لكم شكرا
لفهد القصير في اعداد وانتاج ه الحلقه
ياسر الغانم في اداره التصوير في الاضاءه
اسماعيل شوقي وياسر كدشه في تسجيل الصوت
عبد العزيز المزي وعبد الرزاق المزي وفي
التحرير مرام الضبيبان وفي الهندسه
الصوتيه محمد الحسن واداره الانتاج عبد
المجيد عمر وفي الاشراف على الانتاج غيداء
التميمي هذا سقراط احد منتجات شركه ثمانيه
للنشر
os